artificial intelligence is
revolutionizing the way we interact with
technology chat GPT and AI driven
chatbot is a prime example of this
Innovation with its ability to engage in
natural conversations and understand
contacts chat GPT is reshaping customer
service and automation making it a key
player in the world of AI in this chat
gbt full course we will explore how chat
GPT is useful in various domains what is
chat GPT and how to use chat GPT how
strong are the competitors of chat GPT
and much more so before we begin
consider subscribing to Simply learn and
hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from us over to our tutors on
that note enhance your professional
prospects through enrollment in
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning from Simply learn offered in
partnership with both Purdue University
and IBM acquire sought after
competencies encompassing machine
learning deep learning natural language
processing computer vision reinforcement
learning generative AI prompt
engineering chat GPT and married of
other cutting-edge topics one year of
experience is preferred to enroll in
this course hurry up and enroll Now find
the course Link in the description box
whether you attack Enthusiast a expert
or just curious about the new and
exciting development you won't want to
miss this discussion about the latest AI
sensation I'm talking about chat gbt a
highly Advanced language model based on
gpt3 technology developed by open AI
chair GPD is a state of art language
generation AI model that has captured
the attention of millions of people
around the world it has been trained on
a massive data set of text Data making
it one of the most largest language
models to date but do you know a new
version of GPD is coming up it's called
gpd4 and it will support up to 1
trillion parameters compared to 175
billion parameters of gbt now you might
be wondering what are these parameters
so what it means when a user sends a
query to the New Year version of star
GPT then it will process that query with
all one trillion parameters to deliver a
correct and suitable response isn't it
mind-blowing not only that GPT 4 will
have more applications than its
predecessor gpt3 the gpt3 has various
applications like text generation Tech
summarization automated content
generation application and is also being
used by various companies like viable
Fable studio and algolia aside from its
remarkable language handling ability
gpt4 has the possibility of being
utilized for additional functions such
as generating images and videos this is
due to the fact gpt4 is constructed
using the Transformer architecture which
has demonstrated Effectiveness in
multiple machine learning assignments
including computer vision psychologist
and cognitive scientist Gary marker said
that he can guarantee that GPT 4 will
blow the mines He also mentioned that
gpt4 will totally Eclipse chair gbt as
it has more parameters and is being
trained with more data however the CEO
Sam Altman debunks false information
surrounding the company's upcoming chat
gpt4 aldman said that he did not have an
actual AGI that is an artificial general
intelligence that could travel humans in
learning and existence
the release of chat GPT and other AI
powered chatbots had has a major impact
on Google search business with the New
York Times reporting that it prompted
Google's management to declare State
emergency referred to as code red gpt4
with its improved complexity and quicker
response time has the potential to
enhance communication by making it more
natural and accurate for instance short
sentence responses from a chat board can
reduce the likelihood of people clicking
on ads this AI technology could bring
about a major transformation in the
economy Google employees have been
assigned the task of developing AI
products with gpt4 that can match the
capability of gpt3 such as its
capability of generating art music and
other visuals that open AI is currently
capable of Microsoft has invested 3
billion dollars into the open Ai and is
reportedly in discussion to invest an
additional 10 billion as deported by the
New York Times the paper also stated
that the release of gpd4 is expected to
take place in the first quarter of 22 3
Matt mcelveen a venture capitalist with
knowledge of GPT 4 hinted that the new
system May possesses multimodal
capabilities which refers to the
capability of functioning in various
modes such as text images and songs
the gpt4 chatbot built using Microsoft
extensive data center network has the
potential to be similar to chatgpt
generating only text or it could be
incorporate both text and images however
Sam outman has cautioned not to set
expectations too high so at this point
it is difficult to say with certainty
what GPT 4 will look like and what it
will be capable of so what do you think
about chatgpt4 do let us know in the
comment section below we'll start with a
chat GPT to automate our Excel and we
have some Excel files I will upload them
in the link with the GitHub so you can
freely download them and you can also
try this project with those files and
here we are with the chat jpt so now we
are on the chatgpt website and here you
can see
that they said try chat jpd option and
when we click it we will be redacting to
the chat jbt the chat box and before
that I will show you the home page
it's showing us the samples what we can
do with the chatgpt
the methods
and there's the collect demonstration
data and train a supervised policy like
how it's trained how open AI has trained
the chatgpt and its limitations
they have mentioned all the things here
iterative deployment
and moving on
now we'll log in
to our chat repeating
I will log in with my Google account
tell us about you and this is my name
and he's asking
my phone number
so I will get this blood so you guys
won't be seeing my phone number okay
and it's asking for the code
I am waiting for the code after entering
the OTP you will be directed to this
page that is chat GPT and this is the
feed box where you can write any query
in the simple natural language that
would be English and the chat GPT would
answer your questions
and if we talk about chat jpt uh little
bit information about Judge everybody
that it's an AI powered chatbot that has
been developed by open Ai and the
chatbot understands natural language and
response in a human-like manner it is
based on GPT 3.5 which is a language
model
and the chatbot was unveiled as a
prototype on November 30 2022 while
announcing the chatbot open AI wrote on
its announcement page that we have
trained a model called chat jpt which
interacts in a conversational way the
dialogue format makes it possible for
chat GPD to answer follow questions
admit its mistake challenge incorrect
premises and reject inappropriate
requests so now we will talk about the
chat jibeti so chat jbt is an AI powered
chat board that has been developed by
the artificial intelligence and it's
been researched by the company open Ai
and the chatbot understands natural
language and responds in a human-like
manner it is based on GPT 3.5 which is a
language model the chatbot was unveiled
as a prototype on November 30 2022 while
announcing the chatbot open AI wrote on
its announcement page that we have
trained a model called chat GPD which
interacts in a conversational way the
dialog format makes it possible for chat
GPT to answer follow-up questions admit
its mistake challenge incorrect premises
and reject inappropriate requests
so this is jgpd and it's been boing all
the developers around the globe
so now we'll start with automating Excel
with the help of chat jpt and with the
help of Python language
so first
we will create a folder and see the
Excel files with which
we will use Python and with the help of
chat GPT
we will automate them
so first we'll create a folder for our
project and we will create in Python
projects and name it as
automate Excel using
chatgpt
and inside this
we will open the command prompt
and now we'll open any idea link so that
we will write a request to chat GPT and
he'll answer us with the suitable code
and that code will copy paste into rid
Ali and run it if it gives any error we
will copy paste the error same to the
chat jpt and as I know he answers them
so here
we will open our ideally and for that we
are writing a command that is code space
period and that will open our ideally
that is Visual Studio mode
now
we have open our ideally and first we'll
create a file here
or first we will see our Excel files on
which we will do the automation
and for that we'll get back to our
folder
and here we have the number folder in
which we have two files that is CSV
files
phone number and phone number two
and other we have the sales folder and
in that we have the data of the sales of
the Year 2022
so we'll use these files
sales and the number
so we'll cut them and
get to a folder
and inside the number file no we'll
start with sales
first we'll do the automation
with the sales files
so we'll open the sales folder
and inside that we will create a file
that would be the py file
and the first automation we would be
doing is concatenating all the files in
a single Excel file we have the files
from January to December that is the
sales files so we will concatenate them
and ask the chat GPT to write the code
sorry to concatenate all these
so for that
we'll name the file as concatenate only
Nate
underscore data Dot py
so now
we will give the command to the chat GPT
so here is a child GPD and here
we will write a command for it
that would be I have 12 Excel files
and I want to concatenate them
and we'll also mention the name named
January
is this only
but we'll check with the final January
and then we have February
and moving on
so on we have till December
so we have all these 12 files and now we
will command him
to use python
to concatenate the data inside the 12
axis files into one file
so this is our Command and it's in the
simplest natural language that is the
English language so we'll just press
enter
okay it shows us that an error occurred
if the issue is
so for this thing we will just copy the
open a link and paste it here and open
it
as the chat jpd is seeing a huge traffic
sometimes it shows
these errors
so he's very famous but we are a robot
or not
so
we will agree with the charge ability
and answer its questions here
it's asking again okay now we are clear
with the charge ability and we'll paste
our Command here and press enter
and here you can see that it has started
answering our question that you can use
the pandas library in Python to read in
the data from each of the Excel files
and use the concat function to combine
the data from all levels into one data
frame here's an example of how you want
to use okay
is going you know very right menu
and he has imported pandas and then
create a data name and
using the for Loop
is going through all the months
reading the Excel file
and appending okay done
and result he is concatenating but he
has not created the
Excel file where we can see all the data
and he has also not printed it so what
we want so first we'll see
what does this code do as I have seen so
it will concatenate but it has not
created the Excel file in which we can
see all the data
so we have copied the code we'll paste
it here
save it and run it
and most important thing you have to
import the pandas Library
and if you have not installed it please
install it in the command prompt with
the command pip install pandas or you
can use it in the terminal
okay
it has not found
the january.xls
okay so jnuar by
look at spanning we will see
what error it expects
I will save this and run once again
so we'll just copy the error and write
it back to chat GPT and see
how does it respond
okay is seeing is indicating that the
panel library is unable to find the
Excel file you are trying to read in
based on the error message look like the
files are not located in the same
directory as the python script
okay we'll see that but we have
the python script and the library
in the same
folder
yeah
and we'll check once again here
let's go data.py yeah
they are in the same folder and why we
have this error
okay into
so there it is we have opened our
ideally
in
the automated Excel using chat GPD
folder and currently we are in sales
folder
so it is not recognizing
the directory
so what we'll do
we'll copy all these files
copy the sales files
and paste it here
now
now we will run the port that
chat Jeopardy provided us
okay uh yeah it has run successfully
is good successfully okay we'll try once
again we'll kill the terminal
save it and run it again
now we'll see yeah it has executed
successfully uh but the thing is it has
note
converted it into
a single Excel file for that we will
write
you forgot
to
create
the concatenated
file
as we also haven't mentioned in our
Command
specifically
so we have to be specific with our
commands also
let's see
yeah after creating the data frame
to export to a Excel file and we can
just write this command
and index equal to false here okay and
he's giving all the explanations so you
can just read them you are correct I
apologize for the oversight to create a
new Excel file light contains a concrete
data you can use the to underscore Excel
method of the data frame here is an
example of how you could do this okay
you create a new Excel file name
concerned window underscore data.xl SX
the same directory as your python script
and it will contain the concatenated
data form
from all of the original Excel file you
could also use a to underscore CSU
method to save the data frame in CSV
format yeah
we can do that also
okay I will
make the xlsx file
and just beneath it
okay uh
yeah
C part two uh
okay
we don't need any path we'll just do it
here only
here result.2 Excel
data.xlsx
so we'll save this and run it
is showing that it has executed
successfully
and yeah outside the seeds folder we'll
close it you can see that it has created
the concatenated underscore data.xlsx
so for that yeah it has created it here
will open it
and first I will show you
what these files contain
so every file have the entry of around
thousand
every file has 1000
entries
so the concentrated file should have
around 12 000.
so this is the concentrated underscore
data
and if we go beneath
yeah we can see
and it's 12 yeah it says it has
concatenated all the data
so yeah chat GPT responded and we have
to precise with the commands what we are
writing in English
as it has not mentioned to convert it
into Excel file now when we have written
it again it has done that
now moving on we will do the second
automation
and for that we'll move back to our
ideally and the next automation we would
be doing would be
that we will be
using the sum and the average function
to all the files that is from January to
December files and will
use sum and average function I will show
you we will use
so it's concatenated data
so we'll open the August file
and here
you can see the
quantity in the edge column
so we'll average down the quantity
so what is the average per customer
and
in the J column we have the total cost
so we'll add all the cost in all the
files
this is the August file from January to
December we will do in column match
the average for the quantities and
column J will do the sum of the total
amount per customer
and we'll get it printed at the last
column
that would be we have the Thousand
entries
it's going till
h1001 so we would get it printed on
h1002 and the sum would get it printed
on j1002
okay so moving on we'll close these
files
we will get back to a chat upd and give
him a command that
I have 12 Excel files
and we'll tell him that we have named
them
January
then we have
February
then
we have till December
and now
we want you to use python
to
apply
the sum formula
the sum formula and the average formula
so the sum formula would be applied from
J2 to j1001
let's see okay we have close file you
have a random number
some formula
ROM
J2 to j1001
okay and
the average function
and now we want him to use the average
formula
from H2 to h1001
okay and that would be in all the Excel
files
and we want him to write the results
in the cells and that would be J one
double zero two
and
h1002 is respectively
so we have to be precise with the
commands and we have
an error here that is done and yeah it's
all done
now just
give this command to charge jpt and see
how it answers use dependence library in
Python to renew okay
and perform the sum and average
calculations good and then write the
results back to the same file here is an
example of how you could do this
yeah we are writing in the same file
okay we are importing planner is PD and
running a loop for all the months we
have red
all the Excel files one by one and
we are taking the cell
um
location okay and doing the sum
and doing the mean
of the H column yeah it's good
action
yeah
I think it would
do a job
so we'll copy this and create a new file
and name it as
sum Dot py
and inside this we will paste the code
that our GPT has provided us
and we'll run this
and it has executed successfully okay no
uh we got an error that is
it has made the mistake
and rooted
okay let me just see what query
Speed Run I have 12xl files name in
general every two the Summoner news
python to apply the sum formula from J2
to
j1001 and the average formula from H2 to
h1001 in all the files and write the
results
okay
done
uh we would be a little specific
let's send
j102
and okay
okay okay yeah
we'll once again submit it if we didn't
get
okay yeah now he has used open
yxl Library that's all
yeah
that would be working for us
let's see
what he will provide to us
okay
and
yeah
I think
uh you can solve the purpose but first
we'll run it
so he is
giving us the explanation for what he
has written this code that is this code
will apply the sum formula to the range
j22 j1001 and the average formula to the
range H2 to h1001 in all the Excel files
the results will be written in j1002 and
h1002 respectively it is important to
note that this code will overwrite the
original file so that it's recommended
to make a backup okay we don't need that
and we have backup in the sales folder
also so you can also the read underscore
excellent to underscore Excel function
from pattern
okay
so we'll try this code
uh it is node
I tend to import OS and guys uh you have
to install all these libraries open py
Excel I have already installed them you
can search on the browser that open py
Excel installation Python and it would
be directed to pypi.com that's the
official website for the particular
libraries and there you can see the
command that will be the PIP install and
the particular command for the module
name
it is showing that it has run
successfully so we'll just see
if it has done its job or not
and in the April file we have in the H
column that is the average of the edge
column that puts the items and in the J
column we have the total sum of the
amount of the customers yeah
the query has run successfully chat GPT
has provided us with the perfect code
hats off to the jet GPT and moving on
now we'll do some other automations
and now
what we can do
uh
we have other files that is phone number
and phone number two
and what it contains
it contains the phone numbers
so what we could do is
we could add the plus 91 extension that
is the country code for India
to add the country code plus 91 to both
the files
so I'll close these files
and first
we'll copy them and paste in our
root directory so we don't get any error
and we'll
change the slide
name
instead of iPhone
we will add the underscore
okay
no
we'll move back to charge APD and write
a command
and these files are CSV files node xlsx
file
yeah these are CSV files both the files
are cable files other files are xlsx
files
okay so for that we'll write the command
to charity that
I have two files
uh
with DOT CSV extension
and they are named
phone underscore
number and the second was named
phone underscore number underscore 2.
okay so we have told the jet GPT that we
have two files and now we will tell him
to use python
to add the country code
and the
country
code
plus nine one
as
string prefix
and that would be adding as a string
prefix else it would only show nine one
it won't show plus so we'll see if chat
GPT understands that or not
as string prefix in both the CSV files
with
column name that was phone
okay now we'll just press enter
and wait for a charge APD to answer this
query
and we'll see
how it responds
you can use the printers as well okay
and the prefix to the phone numbers and
the modified data packages are okay
[Music]
now we are building
yes
[Music]
it's heading as step string okay it has
understood that
and to CSV
and this code will hit in both the files
here I think this will work
we have coped account it's controlled in
both CSV files and the plus timeline
string to the phone numbers and
write the modify data background sales
files it's modern to know that this will
or write the original file so it's
required to make a backup with Originals
okay
I could also use the apply function to
add the prefix to the phone number in
the column okay
okay we can do this also
with the Lambda function
and that's what
this will also do a job
first we'll see this
and we will
create a file
for this Automation and name it as
country code dot py okay
and we'll
paste the code here
and run it for you guys
but showing that it has executed
successfully
uh yeah it has executed successfully
so we'll just
go back to our files
and see
whether the code plus 91 as in prefix or
not okay the numbers
okay the files code only nine one as
the column it's still in the number
format
it hasn't
converted into string format
uh we'll see the second code also
like
yeah it has converted x windows ring
okay Lambda X we'll see
whether it's working or not
it has worked uh and the issue is we
have
change the files permission denied okay
we have opened a file we'll close it
on Save
this and run it again
now it shows it has
executed successfully
we'll open the files
and now if we see
it is showing here now it has added two
nine months
you know
uh so no issues
uh the thing is first we have to
transform it into the string format and
then we can add plus nine one as a
string to that string
so chat Jeopardy misses with the
slightest
implementation the code
now moving on uh we'll see this command
later
if you want to see how we can add Plus
90 I will tell you how to write that
code
okay
so now moving on we will do another
Automation and you would be glad to know
that chat jpt improves the existing code
like uh in the first automation it has
concatenated but it hasn't converted
double concatenated file like it hasn't
created that file it had created the
file when we have written to it that you
forgot to create that file so chat jpd
it modulates the existing code also
and moving on
now
in any
okay we'll open the concatenated
underscore data Dot xlsx
and inside this
okay we have the product line
so what we'll do is we will change the
name of the electronic assessors to
electronic equipments and home and
lifestyle to Lifestyle
now we'll automate this process
and we can do this automation all the
files also from January to December
so we'll do that only okay
now here
we will command s
okay now we'll command the charge Deputy
that using python
I trade
through
all the Excel files
in the
directory so we are asking him to
iterate to all the Excel files in the
directory and we will ask him to replace
electronic assessors
electronic accessories
see the spelling
accessories okay
yeah electronic SSS with electronic
equipments
and
also ask him
equipments um
[Music]
okay we'll do equipment only
and
home and lifestyle we have chosen yeah
home and lifestyle
and
change it with only
lifestyle
okay so using python we are iterating
through all the Excel files and changing
these
that would be in each Excel file
so we have to be specific without
written language and now we'll save the
modified workbook in
um we'll create another folder and in
that we will save the files
okay
save the
modified
file
in the
out
put folder
and if the folder is not created
we'll ask him to create it
okay
then create one
hold on
add it in
okay oh I don't know why I'm saving this
so I have written that one I will press
enter
so that charge upd can process it and
give us the
code for that
so it's showing us
sweating and that was sure what you're
showing us
uh you can use the OS library to all the
Excel files and indirectly the panel is
laminated to read in the files and make
the changes and I'm Gonna Save the
modified files okay here's an example of
how you could do this
now here
we imported OS pandas is PD
and it has written the code I mean copy
that this code will literate to all the
Excel files in the current directory
replace electronic recesses with
electronic equipment and home and
lifestyle with lifestyle in the data
frame and then save the modified files
in the output folder if the sorry in the
output folder doesn't exist the script
will create it
you would also use replace function to
replace values in the column okay
and they should write it through all the
cells in each row of the Excel sheet and
replace electronic accessories with
electron equipment and women lifestyle
with lifestyle if the cell value is
equal to the respective string okay we
have copied a code
and now
we will create a file
and
name it as itrade.py
it paste the code here and run it for
you guys
the code has been executed successfully
now we'll see
open all the files not all but yeah let
me open some
that was the previous Electronics this
is
okay so it hasn't changed
in this
okay we will open another file
and see if we code the changes in that
or not
that also States the electronic
accessories so it hasn't
done its job
so we'll move back to GPT
and use this code if it functions else
we will write back to the chair GPD
okay
just a second and read the whole okay we
are using the replace
and find in excellence
okay
so for that you have to report the
OS
done
known underscore book
and for that
let me bought this
and run it
into these files
okay
now we'll see
if we quote our solution or not
no it's showing electronic accessories
and home and lifestyle
so
chat GPT doesn't
go to the code to change them
so we'll ask him another time and with a
different language this time
so I don't think it has created the
output folder
it has oh sorry
I'm really sorry what I have done is my
mistake
those were the original files
and we have the product line here
and we have electronic accessories here
and that should be equipments
okay uh we have electronic accessories
and lifestyle
let me see my command
okay I have asked them to
change Electronics with electronic
equipment and
My Lifestyle with live streams so let's
change only lifestyle
and see
okay
uh the E here is small
we'll update that
in the code
you can write this back to chat jpd also
but yeah
first
we'll do this
and what did I showing
notice executed successfully
okay
in the output folder we have the
December
accessories
that's in the capital E okay okay
so this code is giving us error
we'll see the last code and copy that
and
try to use this
and close the terminal and run it again
it has executed successfully now we'll
see the file
and that has changed or not it has not
now we'll ask the chat GPD
what have you done brother
using python Android tools Excel files
in the directory and replace electronic
accessories with electronic equipment
and home industrial with lifestyle okay
in each Excel file save the modified
modifiers.com
[Music]
okay
we will ask the same thing once again
to him
and with this electronic accessories oh
sorry
and save the modified file
the output folder and get a folder it
doesn't exist okay
okay
um
[Music]
you haven't seen once again
just don't close these files
has executed successfully now we'll open
it
and now we can see that it has changed
to electronic equipment
electronic equipment
yeah now it has executed successfully
maybe there would be an error with this
while copying it as we have also created
the output folder but we forgot to see
in that folder maybe that will be the
error from our site
now we are done with the
changing of the column names
uh it's the cell names that was
electronic accessories to electron
equipments and home and lifestyle to
Lifestyle
now we'll do the next automation
for that
first we'll open an Excel file
uh this was in the output folder
you can get back to our main directory
and open the file in July
and here
here we will
filter the Excel file or gender
that is we'll select gender as female
and with the unique values in column
City
and we'll extract the data from column A
to q that would be the whole data
and for each Unique city value we'll
create a new Excel file for each City
and that will contain data only for that
City and for females only
and after that we'll save this file in a
folder name setting so we'll give this
command to chat jpd
and here you can also specify the module
you won't chat chip it to use for the
particular command
here we will be commanding our chat GPT
to use the pandas module and for that
we'll write the command
node command in the natural language
we'll give this command to the chat jbd
and for that we'll write using Python
and pandas
filter the
okay we will just pick a single Excel
file
or we can
pick the concatenated file
that is concatenated underscore data
filter the
concatenated
underscore data
Dot
Excel SX
Excel file
and that would be for gender
female
and by the
unique values in column City
we first will give the command
by the
unique values
in the column
City
and after that we want to extract the
data from column A to q that is the
whole sheet
extract the data
from the column
A2
q and for each Unique city value
for each unique
City
value
now we will extract the data and now
we'll create a new Excel file so for
that also we'll give the command to chat
jpd and we'll write
create a new Excel file
and that would be for each City
okay
so we will write
create a new
Excel file
or each
City
containing
data
only for
that
City
and for females
okay
and save this file in the
City folder
and if it's
not been there
Jeopardy can create the folder for that
also
okay
City folder and
naming the
each file with the city name okay
I mean each file
after the
course
bonding
City
okay
now
if the
CT folder that is we have written a
small City
okay
if the city folder doesn't exist
then create it
before seeing the files
okay
now we have given this command to the
chat GPT and it has responded us with
you can use the pandas Library as we
already mentioned to use that to read in
the continuated underscore data dot xlsx
file and filter the data for gender
female group the data by the unique
values in the city column and extract
the data from the specified columns for
each group and here is an example
so we have Port the code
we'll wait till chat GPT continues
and we can see that the chat GPT has
completed
and
we will copy this code
settings
[Music]
and full setting group in female data
root Group by okay City
and you could also use the agent method
to filter the data frame for female
gender okay first
we'll see
this
and for
that we will create filter.py
and run the code
it has been executed successfully so now
you'll see that the city folder has been
created or not
I'm not able to see the city folder
okay it's been created
so you can see okay it's been created
man it's still empty
so we'll give time
okay and we quote an error it is
okay okay we will pass this error to
chat jpd first
and after that we'll see what's wrong
with this
on your so the error message you're
saying isn't getting that the column
name specified in the list
are not present in the data frame it's
likely that the actual column names in
the data frame are different than the
ones you specified in the list
okay you just see the list
that is concatenated data
go back
and see that is A2
okay it's still r
okay made a little mistake here
so we'll just
change our Command
yeah
this is it
and
instead of Q now we'll write r and save
and submit now we'll see what it would
generate for us
I'm going to close this
foreign
great and extract the data from the
column a Tor for each Unique city name
and then create a new Excel file for
each City containing data only for that
City and for females files will be saved
in the city folder naming each file
after the corresponding setting okay
done now we'll copy this code
and paste it here and see
whether this code works for us or not
so it's been executed successfully now
we have moved to the city okay it's
executing so we'll give time
to the code
and it do it so yeah it's been execute
successfully
okay so there were three cities that was
Mandalay
and Yangon
and if I show you the data
and you could see
there's c three cities and it has
created the Excel files with the name of
the Cities only the unique cities and it
has extracted the data for the gender
female
now we'll see those files
close this
and back
in the city folder
could see them and lay City
and the data is just for the females
so this automation works well with
chatgpt
now moving on we will do one more
automation
and that would be to use Python to
identify what is the count of each
payment mode
so for that
I will just
get you aware of the payment modes in
our sheet and we'll do this automation
on the concatenated data sheet only
so this is the payment column and you
can see the amount of payments that is
evolet cash credit card
and these are repeating so we will use
Python to identify what is the count of
each payment mode from column m
and that is from this sheet only and
then we'll create a new sheet and name
it as
count.xlsx and write the count against
each payment method
so we'll give this command to our chat
GPT
and ask him to write the code for our
automation
so we're writing use Python to identify
use Python to identify
what is the
count
of
each
payment method
from
column and the column was n from column
n
and that was in
concatenated
underscore data dot xlsx sheet
and
create a new sheet
named
count Dot xlsx
and
write the count
against
each payment method
okay
now we have given this command to our
charge APD and we'll see what it offers
to us you can use the pandas library
today okay that's the same value counts
function to get the count of each main
method okay and you can use the 2XL
method to the data frame to write the
count to a new sheet okay that's good
and he has imported the pandas library
and create the
DF variable in which he has read the
concatenated file and used counts
function with payment method
and when we go to okay the column name
is payment
note payment method I think it would
generate
an error for us
so
it's python of each one method from
column
n
and we will specify
column M and that is named
payment
as it has used payment method here you
can see
that it has used the
column name s payment method
so we will specify this
we have to be very specific with our
commands
for these automations for simple tasks
you can use
simple language
no complex sentences or you have to
mention every detail but for these
automations you have to use them
now our chair GPD is working with this
and mostly he will deliver us with the
perfect code I hope so
okay uh
test right and the value gone and it has
exported
mode reset
you would also have function method and
use the size
method okay
okay we'll see this
oh
and here
we will create a file
as count.py
and in this file we'll paste the code
delivered us by the chair GPT
we have
executed it
s being executed we'll wait for that
it's mean execute successfully
so we have back to our folder
and we have to look for
well count final yeah count file
okay
it just no it doesn't okay yeah it's
showing us the
mode of payment status ewallet cash
credit card and the number of
usage
yeah it's 12 000 that was the whole
entry of the account candidate
underscore data dot xlsx so we have done
with this Automation and now we'll do
one last automation
and first we'll
close all these files
okay
and going back to our chat GPT and now
we will do
we will rename all the 12 Excel files
that was January February to December
and we will add the word
or car sales
just before the month name that would we
will just add the prefix before the
month name
and for that
we will give the command to the chat GPT
in the natural language
and here only we'll change it in the mid
director only as we have the copy of all
these files
so for this we'll write the command use
python
rename
all the 12 Excel files
named
January
February
until December
okay
and that is present in my
directory
and what we have to do is we have to
add
uh the board
will add Car Sales okay
car sales
and
in front of
each
each file name
okay
so what it will do is Car Sales
underscore January Car Sales underscore
February and so on
so we'll wait for the chat GPD you can
use the OS library to iterate through
all the Excel files in indictment then
use the restore training function okay
to rename the files here is an example
of how you could do this
go to S and we have the months
okay
this code will iterate through all the
Excel files in the current directory and
add car sales in front of each file name
and those files would be those only the
months
and good it's using the glow module
and you could also use the Chrome model
okay that's the second code
is even okay
but we'll go with OS first
and get back to R
ideally and name the file as rename Dot
py
and here we'll paste the code
and run it
it's been executed will move back yeah
you could see that car sales have been
added to all the files
and with that we have done with our
automations
and if you want you can also submit your
code to chatgpt and ask it to add
commands to your code so that it could
explain you what that line does or what
that function does it would explain very
tediously and
if you want you can also try chat gbd to
automate many office tasks
you can automate PowerPoint for that and
do many more tasks with chat jpd and
hence your professional prospects
through enrollment in postgraduate
program in Ai and machine learning from
Simply learn one year of experience is
preferred to enroll in this course hurry
up and enroll Now find the course Link
in the description box during our
childhood we have heard the fictional
stories of robots taking over various
household courses making the lives of
humans easy peasy but if you are not
aware then these fictional stories are
turning into reality though not in the
form of physical robots but yes in the
form of computer programs and apps with
the help of artificial intelligence and
machine learning Technologies
confused let me introduce to you to chat
GPT a pre-trained model that interacts
with user in a conversational way chat
GPT is founded by open Ai and the model
is based on supervised and reinforcement
learning so are you excited to know more
about chargpt chat GPT has various
application in various domains in this
video we are going to see the
application of chat gbt in the SEO
domain also we are going to discuss how
chargpt will play an important role in
search engine optimization so here is a
question for you chat GPT is based on
which of the following GPT models
created by openai Option 1 chat gpt1
option 2 chat gbd2 option 3 chat GPT 3
and option for none of the above let us
know your answer in the comment section
below and if your answer is correct you
will get a
as we discussed earlier Chad GPT is the
application of artificial intelligence
and machine learning we know that SEO
rankings depends on various factors like
on-page optimization of page
optimization and more while using chat
gbd we will understand how chat GPT
helps in various SEO ranking parameters
and reduces the manual work so without
any further delay let's begin so to
begin with let's open chat GPT
we need to go to new chat which is
already open here
let's start by we will try to
demonstrate an SEO optimized blog in
this demonstration so let's get some
keyword ideas for the blog so before
that let's choose what kind of blog we
want to create I really love traveling
so let's try to create a travel blog so
for the travel blog we'll find some good
keywords
foreign
so here you can see we are getting some
suggestions for the travel destinations
we can choose any of them
okay so here we got around seven of the
results
so let's try to get something for Japan
so just me with keywords to create a
blog
born with Japan
okay so what I understand from this is
we are just getting few of the random
keywords
Okay so
it is
it is showing that these keywords cover
a range of topics related to Japanese
culture history food and more
uh out of these I guess
we can start
with the places here are a few places
like Mount Fiji
Tokyo and everything so let's try to
create a blog
on top 10 places to visit in Japan
okay so we are getting places to visit
in Japan
foreign
let's try to get keywords related to top
10 places in Japan
okay so we are getting some of the
keyword recommendations
and it is also suggesting that by using
these keywords our content will be more
discoverable and it will be easy for
rank for search for for search rankings
write me a Blog on
top 10
places
to visit
in
goodbye
so the idea is we will try to write a
blog and after which we will try to
optimize the block with respect to the
keyword top 10 places to visit in Japan
and we will also see whether all the SEO
practices can be easily applicable or
not using chat GPT
so here you can see we are getting a
Blog with the introduction with top 10
places and probably what I expect is to
get a good conclusion out of it
also like uh uh a chat jpg provides you
the facility so that you can reduce the
length of your content the textual
content the blog or article or anything
you want to several number of words like
if this Blog has two thousand or five
thousand words you can just ask chat GPT
reduce it to two thousand or thousand
words also
so here you can see that
before when we searched there were only
one liners about these destinations
these places in Japan and now we are
getting a detail about all the 10 places
definitely we have targeted this block
for the uh keyword top 10 places to
visit in Japan however we can ask for
some more key words
to increase its reach
suggest
you
more relevant
keywords for my blog
okay so we are getting some more
keywords here
for any blog it is really important to
have a very good title so we will try to
implement a catchy title for this blog
as a good title helps the user to click
on your
content and it increases the possibility
to get more and more traffic
so here you can see the title is
completely keyword optimize our keyword
is top 10 places to visit in Japan and
here I can see most of the suggestions
most of the suggested titles have the
keyword top 10 places or top 10
destinations which are somewhat similar
to what we are expecting
at the best
suitable title
in my blog
okay so we are getting something
different here The Ultimate Guide to
Japan's hidden gems 10 places you can't
miss
okay so here we got title for a Blog but
here we can see there is a slight
limitation that it is suggesting the
title but it is not adding it to our
blog and representing it again to us
optimize my blog
for the keyword
top 10
visit in Japan top 10 places to visit in
Japan
but then
optimized
title
okay so we have to do it manually it's
not able to
add the title on the Block
optimize
my blog
for the
keyword
top 10 places to visit and which
okay so it is showing the relevant
suggestions
so maybe there is a slight
ambiguity in the query that's why it's
not representing us the correct results
we are going to optimize our blog using
all these factors
foreign
again these are the suggestions
let's try to implement these one by one
foreign
s H1 H2
in the above block
so yes we are getting the updated
versions having H1 and H2
and yes you can see easily that the
title of the blog is in H1 and the rest
are maybe in H2
H1 and S2 tags are some of the practices
in the on-page optimization which helps
the search engine boards to understand
that this is something important really
important for the page and they pick up
these hints for getting your page rank
so yes it is implemented
okay so our blog is completed with H1
and H2 implementations
let's try to get some interlinks for
this blog interlinks have their own
importance as interlinking your blog
with other pages of your website or your
blogging Pages this will help you to
gain the traffic from other pages to
your blog and putting the traffic from
your blog to other pages of your website
also it helps the search engine boards
to understand the crawl structure
understand the website structure also
so
suggest me if you would
intern links
for the above block
so yes definitely these are the relevant
and expected links we are getting so if
you have any of these uh blog pages in
your website or if you have created any
of these blogs earlier do Interlink it
which of the above
can I use in my blog so definitely there
are number of suggestions but if you
want to choose one how can you pick the
one let's see if we get the relevant
thing for this
okay
so it is not only suggesting that we can
use all of the above
but it is also showing the significance
of interlinking
okay moving ahead
so till now we have optimized our blog
for a keyword top 10 places we have
tried to get some of the keywords
relevant to the top 10 places to visit
in Japan we have added headings and we
have tried to get some of the good
Interlink suggestions to add interlinks
in our blogs which are some of the good
practices of the on-page optimizations
so next moving ahead in another on-page
optimization technique is let's try to
get a cover image for this blog
so by by getting a cover image
suggestions we will try to implement the
image optimization technique for our
blog page
okay so it is showing uh some of the
suggestions related to
the diversity of the country the normic
view of Tokyo Skyline the beautiful
image of kuyoto's traditional Temple
Mount Fuji hiroshima's peace Memorial
Park
so we will try to pick one and see if we
are getting any image idea
let's take for Mount Fuji
suggest me the image idea for Mount
so let's see we have seen in genetic for
all now let's see for this uh image
suggestion specific to Mount Fuji
okay definitely it is showing a number
of suggestions for the specific Mount
Fuji image
so if you are looking to create another
block for Mount Fuji then these ideas
are easy to take up
optimize
amount
Fuji image for my blog
here are some tips to optimize the image
for Mount Fuji for my blog which are
they're showing that the image should be
high resolution
then a clear subject
definitely if you have a large image a
large file size it really gets difficult
to load and the page load speed will
increase so if you have a large file
size the image should be compressed
without reducing its quality image
quality
we should have descriptive file names
and all tags
okay
so let's try to get a very good file
name and ALT tag also we'll try to
implement a good caption because adding
a caption is very good in the when
considered as a user
so
get me
title and
Alt
tag
for
mount
Z image
so there is importance for ltac as
search engines are the Bots they won't
able to identify the image directly so
all tags helps the search engines to
understand what the image is about
so yes it is showing not one but number
of suggestions for all the Mount Fuji
recommendations which we got earlier
so we will try to choose one and get a
caption for it
right a good
caption
for
for the image
scenic
fusy
Five Lakes Region
so yes definitely we're getting
suggestions here
I guess this caption is quite long so
let's try to reduce it to
40 words
reduce the above
caption
to
not even 40 let's do it in 20 20 words
okay this one is better
now let's try to get the image if there
is any
choose the mound
LG image for my blog
choose image
it should not repeat
choose the perfect
illustration for
amount Fusion
image for my
blog
so you can see here that it is not
choosing any image but it is again
providing us a suggestion what we can
choose
again this is the limitation that it is
not showing us any of the image we will
try to put it in another way to get an
image
if it really works we can get it
okay so it is not possible to download
or get an image representation using
chat GPT
we can only get the recommendations to
choose the image and yes it is showing
some suggestions of an unsplash pixels
or Shadow stock to download the image so
we can really navigate to these websites
and download some of the required image
for our blog
so we we have completed here with the
image optimizations let's try to get
some video ideas because again having a
video is a catchy factor for the users
visiting your website
or your blog page
suggest me
suggest
video ideas
for
above
block
okay so we are getting few of the video
ideas
which of the
above idea is best match for my blog so
try to extract anyone from the above
okay so it is completely dependent on
the user's Choice what a user wants so
here I'll choose
for
again we will continue with Mount Fuji
only
provide with your optimization
optimization ideas
optimizations
for
amount
using video
for above block
okay so it is showing us some of the
suggestions what we uh which we can
Implement for a video as we do not have
any video here we can just take these
recommendations and optimize whatever
the video of our choice
so let's take the thumbnail suggestions
in our next query if it can suggest us a
mount fusey uh thumbnail uh image
suggestion and the video tag suggestion
right
suggest me
good
thumbnail idea
for
Mount Fuji
video
thumbnails have the Major Impact for any
videos it is the only thing
um
I repeat
thumbnails
thumbnails are one of the important
factors which encourages the user to
click on your video and watch the
complete video
so definitely having a good thumbnail
will help your content to rank
so yes we have got around 10 of the
thumbnail ideas from which we can
Implement any one uh as of the video we
are having for our blog
so we are done with the thumbnail ideas
after which we will get
we will try to get video tags so for
getting video tags let's get for all of
them
find me
video
tags for
the
all of above
thumbnail
suggestions
times are important to help the user to
get your videos in the search list
like if someone uh uh types Mount Fuji
in the search box and if the Mount Fuji
keyword is or a tag is added to your
video tag it is more likely to get
searched and appear in the search
results and possibly use a May click on
it
so here we have tried to get uh try to
implement some of the good uh some of
the important
on-page optimization practices now let's
try to get backlinks which is one of the
most famous of page optimization
technique
above block
okay so it is showing
some of the link suggestions
so basically backlinks are the links
which points from other another website
or another web page to your web page or
your website
so getting backlink is one of the trust
factors in the search engine's eyes that
your content is really unique and more
of more users wants to read it and share
it with another users
so the search engines by by these search
engines understand that your content is
really good and it is worth of ranking
so definitely getting a good backlink
from a very good authority websites is
fruitful for your content
so let's try to get
pages
on web are
suitable
to get
backlinks for my blog
so here we are getting some of the ideas
or suggestions that which Pages we can
choose to get a backlink
so here is industry specific websites so
if you are writing a travel blog there
should be a travel trip advice a Trip
Advisor like websites
which are showing more of the trip
oriented or bookings related oriented
for travel or destinations
there are few of the directories
okay government websites which are the
tourism websites in our case right now
blogging websites social media platforms
which can be relevant to the current
scenario which we are using here
so
let's check
how can we get
backlinks
from the
above
recommendations
for my blog
okay guest posting
broken link building
okay these are some of the backlink
building methods which we are getting
so that we can find one and get one of
the blacker
I repeat
so these are some of the battling
building strategies which we are getting
in the recommendation so we can
Implement any of these to get a batting
for our blog
let's choose the specific platform
and try to get the recommendations
or the ideas to get backlinks for the
from the blogging site
so we can Implement these ideas and it
it may be possible to get backlinks
now that we have got some of the ideas
to get backlinks for our blog let's try
to add the catchy metadata for our blog
metadata like having meta title or meta
description these are the only data
which is which is appearing in the
search results as you you have seen that
in the search result the link the Blue
Link we get is the meta title of our
blog page or a website page or any page
on the web whereas a few lines written
below that link is the meta description
that we are providing to let the user
know that what the blog is exactly about
so it is considered to be a good
practice to have the targeted keyword in
the title as well as in the description
so let's try to get one
yes the
create SEO
optimize
meta title and meta
description for my blog
so we are getting some suggestions here
top 10 places to visit in Japan discover
the best place to visit in Japan top 10
destinations definitely we have here top
10 destinations
see also we are getting some of the
notes that
it is good to have meta title less than
60 characters
so if if it is more than 60 character
you may get the dot dot part and the
title will not be clearly visible in the
search result page
so let's try to again optimize The Meta
title and meta description for top 10
places to visit in Japan
description
for the key word
top 10
places to visit in Japan
okay
so we can use any of the one the one we
have got recommendation the previously
and this one also both are completely
relevant to our content
so one of the technical SEO factor which
we are going to see here is getting the
URL recommendation uh URLs are the
important factor uh it helps the search
engine boards to understand about the
page as the URL is the first thing
search engines may be visiting to come
to your page
so
uh it is a good practice to have the
keyword in your url rather than having
some of the abrupt characters like x a r
at the rate these kind of stuffs in the
link
so let's create
the URL suggestions
suggest me
SEO
optimized URL for the
above block
see so here
we are getting top 10 places to visit in
Japan which is definitely our blog and
as a keyword we are using it to optimize
our content and it is placed in the URL
so this URL is completely correct
also these kind of suggestions are very
good for the newbies in the search
engine domain as they will definitely
understand why and what we are doing to
optimize our pages
so next
moving ahead with some of the
non-technical aspects which may impact
which may definitely impact to bring the
traffic so let's try to get some of the
sharing suggestions like
bits
platforms
should I
repeat
which sharing options
should I add
in my
blog
so out of the mentioned sharing buttons
we can add any of them
adding at least three to four sharing
buttons is considered to be really good
out of which there are many common like
Facebook is really common then Reddit is
really very common watchup shells are
really common Twitter Shares are really
common
so you can choose any of these to add it
in your blogs
thus commenting on
my blog
impact
on
traffic source so here we are taking the
suggestion that will this help or not
again this is again linked to the
backlinks that if we are adding the
comment section someone else may ask for
a backing for their web and this is
again going in symbiotic way like if
they are asking for a battling for from
your blog you can even ask from them
so this is the way of or a part of a
communication to get a backlinks as well
can you find the
duplicate
content
above log so duplicate content is a
concept where search engines you you
must be aware that search engines are
really in love with the unique content
so having a duplicate content may really
affect your web visibility and it is
possible that your page may get dead
after a Time
so plagiarism is not at all allowed uh
when you're creating a content
it is not suggested in any case
okay so it is not able to charge
everybody is not able to identify the
duplicate content however it is
suggesting that some of the tools like
copyscape or sideliner to understand if
the content we are creating for our blog
is duplicate or not
and let's get some suggestions how to
make
content unique
just in case if someone is not aware to
create a unique content
we can get some of the tips here
okay so we have got some of the
suggestions Also let's try to uh see one
of the other aspects of technical SEO
that is 404 Pages four not four pages
are
really
not are not likely to get searched
because
I repeat
let's try to see another aspect of
technical SEO
uh try to find some four not four pages
on the website
foreign
so from this I can understand that
though we have not posted any blog link
or any uh internal links that leads to
that blog which we are expecting this is
not the clear idea we are providing but
yes uh to find four not four pages
uh it is not possible for the chat GPT
to get one but we can use some of the
tools suggested like a screaming frog or
Google search console where we get the
detailed report of the broken links or
404 pages that is the dead pages of a
website
so let's wrap up from the view of the
technical SEO perspective
please consider one of the scenario that
we have published this blog and how can
we promote this blog to reach more of
the relevant audience
so
okay so we are getting some of the
recommendations that we can share our
blog on social media reach to the
influencer add it as a guest post
and Link back to this
this blog email marketing yes it is the
most trending technique to reach more of
the audiences
paid advertising commenting
content syndication
yes medium and Linkedin are the very
famous platforms for this
online communities
so you can you can definitely try to be
the member of the online communities and
forums where you can just put up the
link and the members of your Niche may
definitely visit your
a content and share it with others also
so yes we we have seen that uh search
for as as a perspective of search engine
optimization chat GPT is uh helpful
really really helpful to create the in
content Creation in optimizations and
many of the other things
today in an era of mobile devices robots
and social media content creation is the
most effective inbound marketing
strategy
nearly 40 percent of marketers say
content marketing is essential to their
marketing strategy and 81 percent say
their company views content as a
business strategy
original and high quality content can
help your company stand out and attract
your customers and help your business
grow on that note welcome to Simply
learns YouTube channel today we are here
with a fantastic video on chat GPT for
Content creation which will help you
create some compelling content on your
desired topics but before we get started
guys I have a question for you is
chargpt an application and is it
available on Android well let us know
the answer in the comments below so let
us understand what is chat GPT here now
content creation can be of any type such
as blogs podcasts videos graphics and so
on but how do you create high quality
content with a few minutes do not be
worried when we have chat GPT now even
though there are numerous AI writing
tools for Content creation chat GPT
stands for the crowd due to its faster
response rate ease of use increased
productivity support for multiple
languages and other benefits now let's
try to understand what exactly chat
Jupiter is and how to create content
from it
now generally charge GPT is an open AI
trained and developed model that works
conversationally
chat GPT is capable of systematically
resolving all bugs while providing
detailed explanation for each step it
takes so in simple words chat GPT is a
tool that creates content for any query
chart GPT stands out among all the other
achievements of open AI
so let us now move ahead and understand
how does chat GPT work now chart GPT
uses deep learning techniques to
generate human-like text which is based
on a machine learning model derived from
the large language model class now it is
trained on a massive Text data sets from
the internet and learns patterns and
relationship between words and phrases
it responds to a question by selecting
the next word based on the context and
then repeats the process until a stop
condition is fulfilled so as a result
chart GPT can logically respond to your
queries and commands so let's see how to
create content in chat GPT now as we
already discussed content creation can
be of any type so for instance let's
take blog a Blog is an online general or
a website where a writer or a group of
writers shared their views on an
individual subject now there are a
variety of categories for writing a Blog
so let's pick one for chat GPD here
so as you can see we have navigated into
charge APD and let us now ask a simple
question about food blogging now lately
food blogs are the most popular blogs
that everyone wants to write about so
let's find out what chat GPT has to say
about it now you can give any question
to charge GPT and it will answer so I'm
just writing a question here saying how
to
start a foot
blogging carrier
so as you can see it is generating the
answer for us wait for it to end
well as you can see it is saying that
starting a foot block can be a fun and
rewarding way to share your love or food
with others so it is showing us some
steps to get started in food blogging
career it is saying choose Anisha choose
a name and domain choose a blogging
platform create your blog create high
quality content and so on so in this way
charging PPT will automatically generate
the response for you based on the
questions that you are giving input to
it next we will see another question on
lifestyle blogs now with the world on
social media everyone wants to read more
about lifestyle especially of a famous
or a popular entity what habits they
adapt and what to let go of Etc so let's
explore this segment in charge GPT as
well and see what it will show the
answer so let's uh give the question as
how to
start
lifestyle
blogging in India
so it is giving the answer for us guys
so it is saying that starting a
lifestyle blog in India can be a great
way to share your experiences and
knowledge with others who share similar
interests so here are some steps to help
you get started again it is giving some
uh important points whereas in order to
start your lifestyle blogging career
like choose your Niche choose a name and
domain choosing a blogging platform
create your blog create high quality
content and so on chat GPT has been
helping in various Fields like customer
support virtual assistant education
content generation language translation
research and information retrieval
personal productivity entertainment and
more now talking about content creation
then chat GPT can prove a valuable tool
in idea generation writing enhancement
research and fact checking SEO
optimization and social media content
the power of AI has been overcoming
these days so without without any
further Ado let's begin
chair GPT can assist you with content
SEO or search engine optimization in
following ways number one is keyword
research chat GPT can help you to
identify the relevant keywords and key
phrases that are commonly used in your
industry or required for your topic by
discussing your content with chat gbd
you can uncover valuable keywords to
optimize your content for search engines
so let's find some keywords to create
content on shoes we will create a blog
on shoes so let's add query to chat GPT
so here we got few suggestions we can
pick any of them if needed you can check
these keywords in any keyword research
tool to check their search volumes if
you require so let's choose this keyword
let's write a blog using chat GPT in 500
words on this keyword
the next we have is content optimization
chat GPT can provide insights on how to
optimize content for better search
engine rankings it can suggest where to
include keywords naturally within your
content recommends heading structure and
advice on appropriate keyword density so
to the above created blog let's find the
optimization
so here we saw the number of
optimizations suggested by chat GPT for
our content the next we have is meta
tags and descriptions chat GPT can help
you to generate compelling meta tags and
descriptions that accurately represent
your content these elements are
important for search engines to
understand the topic of your content and
display relevant information in search
results so let's ask chat gbd to write a
creative meta descriptions meta title
and meta tags for this block
if needed we can rephrase these meta
descriptions and titles as per our
requirement by providing another query
the next trick to master SEO content
with chat gpts content length and
quality
Jag GPT can guide you on the ideal
length of your content based on the
search engine algorithms and user
preferences it can help you to ensure
that your content is of high quality
engaging and informative which can
positively infect on your SEO ranking so
let's understand what can be the ideal
length of this shoe blog
as we have already written a 500 Words
length of block let's change it to
another one suggested by chat GPT
interlinking and site structure chat GPT
can provide suggestions on how to
structure your content and incorporate
interlinks effectively interlinking
helps search engines to navigate your
website and understand the relationship
between different pages boosting your
overall SEO so let's get few of the link
recommendations for our blogs on shoes
the next one we have is user intent and
readability chat GPT can assist in
understanding user intent and optimizing
your content accordingly by discussing
potential user queries and preferences
you can create content that aligns with
what users are looking for enhancing its
relevance and readability so let's check
out if the readability of the given
block or block created by chat GPT is
good or not
you can also test some other content
with chat GPT to check whether its
readability is good or not while chat
GPT can provide a valuable guidance it's
important to remember that SEO is a
complex field and requires a holistic
approach it's advisable to combine chat
GPT suggestions with best practices
industry knowledge and ongoing SEO
strategies to achieve optimal results
enhance your professional prospects
through enrollment in postgraduate
program in Ai and machine learning from
Simply learn one year of experience is
preferred to enroll in this course hurry
up and enroll Now find the course Link
in the description box
check GPD is truly a fascinating
technology changing how we interact with
language it's the result of years of
research and development by open AI who
have trained the model on a massive
amount of Text data to create a machine
that can easily understand and generate
human-like text imagine you are a
digital marketer looking to make a big
impact on your next campaign chair GPT
can help you do that charge gbt uses
natural language processing or NLP which
can assist you in creating compelling
human-like copy for your website social
media and email marketing it can even
generate product descriptions and AD
copy that is engaging and optimized for
search engines using chat GPT will save
time and increase your productivity
allowing you to focus on other important
aspects of your campaign and with its
ability to generate multiple text
variations you can test and Define your
messaging to find the perfect tone and
language that resonates with your target
audience get ready to revolutionize your
digital marketing game with the help of
this video you will gain a deeper
understanding of how Jan GPT can
supercharge your efforts as a content
creator or digital marketer say goodbye
to mundane tasks and hello to a 10-fold
boost in productivity let's dive in ever
since open AI launched chatgpt it has
been making waves in every feed be it
academic marketing engineering or
content writing so here's a little
trivia for you who are the investors in
open AI the company behind the
development of CIA jpt and your options
are option A Allen musk and Sam Altman
option b Jeff Bezos and Satya nadera
option C Mark Zuckerberg and Larry Page
option D segma and masayoshi Sun Drop
your answer in the comment section below
but before we begin let me ask you if
you are aiming to get certified in
digital marketing and want to build a
career in digital marketing then Unleash
Your digital marketing potential with
simply learn get ahead of the
competition and upskill with simply
learns IMT ghaziabad digital marketing
program learn from industry experts gain
hands-on experience with real world
projects and master inbound and outbound
marketing strategies to drive business
growth
join our committee of successful
Learners today and become a digital
marketing Pro in no time to learn more
about this digital marketing course
check the link in the description box
below
okay then let's get started there are
many uses of chatgpt in digital
marketing its main USB is smart human
sounding content writing we can command
it to write content related to marketing
first owner agenda is an ad copy there
are various ways to go about it but we
must understand that no matter how much
content sounds like humans it is still a
piece of content written by an AI so you
have to give detailed and precise
queries to get the best results let's
start by giving it a basic command like
write an ad copy
[Music]
as you can see it gave us random ad
content let's give this query more
content like write an ad copy for simply
learned digital marketing Master's
course
[Music]
now as you can see it gave us a more
precise ad copy we can also ask to make
it longer or shorter let's give it a
next query can you make it longer
[Music]
and vola it gave us a low version of
that same content now let's try to
convert it into email newsletters we
digital marketers often send emails to
promote our products and services so
let's give it a query as can you convert
it to email newsletters
thank you
as you can see it has generated an email
with a subject line and body that is
enticing and engaging to read we can
also utilize chat GPT to correct grammar
or change the tone of the content for
example let's enter new query what is
Facebook
foreign
[Music]
of Facebook now let's ask it to rephrase
it more engagingly and in a digital
marketing context we can give queries
like can you make it more engaging and
relatable with digital marketing
[Music]
as you can see it has completely
replaced it and it is more interesting
to read it as well chatgpt can also help
with keyword research so let's try it we
will give a query as suggest more such
keywords for a digital marketing course
site
[Music]
thank you
and Bola it has completed a work we used
to spend 10 to 15 minutes in a few
seconds you can request to write blogs
as well let's give it a query to search
for some keywords for the blog suggest
keywords to write a blog on digital
marketing
it gave us some keywords you can ask it
to reduce these topics based on search
volume to get maximum results let's ask
it to narrow it down to five topics
based on keywords volume
[Music]
here we have some suggestions let's pick
a topic content writing and ask it to
write an article on content writing
thank you
[Music]
here we have an article for the blog
let's use chatgpt to SEO optimize it
let's first request it to give us meta
title and meta description
[Music]
here we have meta title and meta
description for this article we can even
request it to give us an SEO optimized
URL link
we can also request it to write the SC
optimized version of this article just
give it a command as also can you as you
optimize this article to improve Google
search results
[Music]
foreign
optimized article with meta title and
meta description where the SEO optimized
URL chat GPT can also be used to train
your customer service chat boards but we
can discuss the process in some other
video chat jbt is well burst with its
content writing capabilities it can even
help you write product marketing
campaigns let's try it with this query
the query is write a product marketing
campaign Force Implement digital
marketing courses
foreign
Ty has done it again this campaign looks
interesting and it will be able to
generate more leads for simple lens
courses chat jpd can also be used to
write scripts for YouTube videos let's
give it a query as write a script for
five net YouTube video promoting simply
learn and its digital marketing courses
foreign
[Music]
as you can see it gave us full script
along with few suggestions for video
editor on where to put logos and clips
to make the video more engaging if you
are a content creator and you don't know
how to approach other content creators
for a collaborative video then chatgpt
can help you with that it can help you
writing collaboration emails as well my
next query will be to write a
collaborative email for a YouTube video
on digital marketing
[Music]
since my last query was related to
Simply learn chatgpt assured that I work
for simplion and I wrote a customer
collaboration email that looks
professional plus easy to read and
understand now let's open the child GPT
and check let's refresh this I have
already opened my chat gbt you can just
log in it and then you are good to go so
let's say hello and see
so it's working completely fine right
now okay
so what will we do today is
we'll open our Visual Studio code I have
created one folder which is Tailwind
it's an empty folder you can just see
that so in that folder we'll add the
Tailwind so first let's ask the chat GPT
to help us install or set up the
Tailwind
so I'll write
please
set up
the
Railway
let's see
okay
so asking us to install node.js first
and then it's asking us to
check the origin of that
okay
it's saying to install these
new programs JavaScript module
to add these components in the CSS file
so this is saying to add this in the CSS
file okay
so
let's check whether it is telling us
something useful or not
post class or don't prefixer
okay
now
simultaneously let's check
the table website
how to install this
so here
it's saying to install this command
CSS and then in it in that project then
it's saying to configure the template
part
to add this to your Tailwind
configure.file
then it's saying to create a folder
input.gss
and then just start the process
so as of now
charge GPT has not given us the correct
answer it's correct but not up to the
mark as you can clearly see the commands
that are given on the
delvin.css official website
uh so according to me many people think
that because of Charity the uh so many
jobs of the developers are in the risk
because charity can create websites all
of this stuff so I don't think so
according to me it's not that good it's
very good for the uh helping any
developer purpose
but it's not that good but let's see we
are in this together
so let's just open the previous Studio
code and install our Tailwind now we'll
ask it to create so many other things so
let's see whether it can create that or
not so I have opened my terminal so many
people also comment us that how you
could open the terminal so I just used
one shortcut Control Plus tactic
to open the terminal you can also go
here
and create one terminal
okay
now I'll paste the line to install
Kelvin CSS in my system
so let's wait a couple of minutes
as you can see it's installed in our
system all the packages and modules are
installed
now it will tell us to init this project
so let's do that
okay
it has successfully created the
configure file now inside the content
we'll copy paste this one
as it is saying to add these line
configure your template path add the
path to all your template file in the
file okay so let's just
copy this thing
and paste in the content
now let's save it
okay
so now next step is add the Tailwind
directives to your CSS
now
what will we do here is
let's go back to Middle Studio code and
create a folder
inside this
Dot
SRC okay and set this SRC we'll create
the file
Beautiful Lord Jesus
hair will face the good yeah okay we
haven't completed that code all yet
so let God be
let's paste it here
so I don't think so again that this can
replace the developers because this is
not the correct we do
tell although it has given us all the
steps but
any developer can do the task in a very
short period of time it can just help
any developer but not
take the job of the developer okay
so let's move ahead
and
step would be
to go back
next step two fill the process
let's copy this one and start the
Tailwind CLI build process okay
let's copy and paste it here
right
as you can see it's done in 273
milliseconds
the output.css is generated in this
test file folder right
now we just have to use this file
output.css okay
let's see now
let's create a
file here
and name it as index dot HTML
okay
and inside that I'll write my Boiler
code just pressing shift N1 for the
discrimination Mark and then the Boiler
code is done so we can change the name
of this
and let's write here as
side
using charging
okay
no
one main thing that I wanted to tell you
that I have installed one extension in
my system which is the live server this
extension you can download
and this is very helpful okay
let's open this one
now what we'll do is we'll link the
output.jss file in our gmail.gss
for that I'll write here link
okay
and inside this ring I will curve or you
can just write link and then click and
then right
here
style sheet
mobile
okay
what we'll do is we'll give the path of
the output.js for that dot dot slash
list
foreign
okay
let's close this link tag and let's save
it and let's just
right click and here you'll see open
with live server when you will install
the extension live server so let's open
this one
so this is working completely fine it's
showing that the title which side is
intently
okay or something
I'll write here
welcome
to Simply learn
and then
let's save it and you will see it's
showing
welcome to Central okay
now the next step would be to create
now let's open our
charge into d and
and we'll ride
create a
concept
header
using
for its first copy this one
in there
that's usually
okay
so
let's see whether it can give us a right
answer this time
it can
let's see
okay
it's giving us the code now for the
header
[Music]
okay
so it is showing us in the above code we
use Tailwind CSS classes to style the
header we set the background color to
Gray and this one is the property of
green color and then the text color
would be a white color in that name bar
inside the header we have a nav element
with the flex and justify between okay
classes to horizontal Center the element
space them out evenly okay fine we also
use PX4 and py3 to add padding to the
navigation bar cool
for the mobile menu we use the button
with the MD hidden class to hide it on
okay let's see the code now
broken
now let's copy this HTML file let it
write everything shown here you don't
need this one so let's delete this
and let's here write header
and let's comment it down
yes okay let's
raise the code and check
whether it's
let's save it and let's go back to our
file so this is what charity created for
us it's looking very good actually
so let's inspect it
and let's see is it responsive or not so
this is completely responsive based
okay very good
yeah
so
this is really very good okay
on Surface Dio
sl20 Ultra this is what
will show on the mobiles okay now we'll
go back to the chat CPT and let's clone
this one
and
stop generating and let's say right
create
a
section using
determine
CSS now let's see something
wrong okay
let's see let's first up with this one
and we press this
and let's see how it will create the
hero section using tell messages
so it has created this never really very
good
I didn't expect this from the activity
but it's really really looking really
good it's simple and you can add these
to another Pages just using the anchor
okay we can just give the path so I'll
show you www dot
[Music]
com
so this one is okay
so whenever I click on this one it will
redirect us to the simulant but the URL
is wrong so you can just go back to
simplylearn.com
and let's copy the
and let's go back to code
and let's write
the URL okay save it let's see
yeah this is how this works
let's close this one okay now let's see
what is the code
okay let's copy this code and let's see
how this is working so it is also giving
us the complete code how it's working
how this step is working and all as you
can see it's giving us the max W with 7
into 1 utility sets as Max weight for
the container I add to 7xl which is 120
112 Ram or 1792 pixels it's giving us
all the explanation for the code it has
written for us
so let's check it
and after the header I'll paste that
code and let's save it and see
okay
this is really really good guys
yeah I didn't expect this from chargpt
but it's looking very good
so
till if I am a developer so if I had to
write this much of code it'll take me
around
two three hours at least but with the
help of charge GPT it only created in
5-10 minutes
this is very good actually now let's
open the charge GPT again and here we'll
create a
in position section
information
using
chairman
let's see now
till now it's working really very good
now it is writing a code for us so as
you can see
let's see
again very good
now let's copy this one and paste it
under this
David
and let's check
so this is the information section this
has created for us
right important information location of
his hours contact us and all right we
can also regenerate it for something
else okay now we it will create
something else for us
right
if you don't like something we can just
regenerate and create another one for
just let's copy this one
now it's telling us everything about the
gold
and here after that I'll write this save
it let's check what's this okay this is
the information section it has created
for us that this is something change
data and if you don't like this one also
you can again regenerate the response
this is really an amazing feature of Cat
DVD
okay so now it's creating the third
option we can countlessly ask him to
create again and again for us
the response
let's copy this one
okay
and let's remove all of it because
it's looking very
clumsy
now let's see okay
this information section is information
section Welcome to our website this is
what it's written
okay
now let's ask him to create something
else okay
let's copy this text create information
same and paste it using Tailwind with
image I'll
check whether it can a response to my
things if I want to create one image on
the left or right side and then the text
on the other side let's see whether it
can create it for us or not okay
create informative section using charge
activity with one image on the
right
and
text on the
left
side
now let's see
where it can create that or not for us
right just in simple
command so we will check whether you can
create or add the image
okay assuming the classes but
text
okay
which class also
and it's taking the source from
an API called unsplash I have covered
this unsplashed API on my previous
videos so again okay now let's copy this
and paste it on our code let's delete
this one and
paste this one on the website
okay
so the image is quite large we can
reduce the sizes but in the starting
only I have told you I will not add
anything in the code so I'm not doing
anything in the code right so we can
change the size it's really good as I
have told him to add the image on the
right side and the text on the left side
it's doing the same for the user so this
is really very helpful for the developer
but as I have already told you it will
cannot replace the developers because I
am the developer I only knows how to do
things as I have showed you that it has
given me so many wrong answers before
that report this one this I have given
me three answers but it was not up to
the mark so I had to told him that took
uh create like this
image on the right and I've explained it
to the HR GPT then it created this one
for us okay and whenever I'll we
rephrase this page the image will get
changed this is the
unflash API how this works okay we can
change the images also
this is random just right here
coding okay
now you will see the images that will
come here okay
let's see
let's check it
it's not taking any other name
it's not working but let's not waste
time on this
random is also fine
till now it's looking really very good
okay
now the next step would be to add the
service section okay so let's charge the
video to create service section okay
foreign
now let's see
it's coming
okay
zooming the class for the side of the
water
element
so look how beautifully it has been
created
right
yeah
okay
let's see
it's done now let's copy the code and go
to our location
and here
will write this code and let's paste it
let's check
okay
so it's not a line straight but we can
align it
so it's only showing you guys that the
services that this website is providing
what we offer and this is some gen data
web design web marketing and all so
let's check whether it is
yeah
okay
so
what this one is doing here is it's
using only
between classes that is using
and the center Center
we all are using the same class but
let's find out why the
image
is coming
like that
right
you can align it
you were guys want me to align this we
can align this right
okay
so
that's just a length one it's just one
line okay we can align that
so let's dig deep into this quote
okay
this image classes
same justify Center and then choosing
the flex shrink function
towards round and large
okay
and domain 56
check
[Music]
and let's go back to the chord
strictly the size of this because
okay
scroll back to the child begin
we generate the new response and let's
see how the second response is looking
right
this week the couple of seconds small
okay let's see the response that it is
creating
we need a minimalist design okay I will
just observing the code and
you
you know it's looking
you can also change the color of the
customizable this website on our own but
it's really really good I'm really
impressed with this this really will
help developers creating websites okay
let's go back to me
still creating
after that we'll create the about
section for the page okay
[Music]
so again giving us that
design and all part
if I'll tell charge UT to create this
service action and this is my
requirement and all it will definitely
create that I guess now I'm just really
impressed with the code clean code it's
writing
and it's also responsive I haven't told
it to create the responsive code but
it's really really good it's a
responsive
I will show you
inspect I will just fill that only
whether it is responsive or not if you
will see it will have been test cut this
card
it's just okay
yeah so this is how we'll check the
responsive I think and let's
see
see that these three
uh home about contacts are managed
and
this is the header part that we created
and then the output is the navbar this
is the information section
and services section is also there
so this is called responsive
okay
so we will check how it's looking on
Samsung Galaxy s20 this is how it's
looking
yeah let's move on to the code copy this
code and coming back to the code editor
let's delete this
section
okay
now let's paste it and see
it's giving us
this is what it created for us
and I guess
little less
or
it was already writing the code and it
stopped
it's fine it's not its mistake then
stopped and
regenerate the response
let's copy this again
coming back
chat
hurricane news
refresh rgbt again
service section let's see
it's really fast now
okay
let's observe this one first
Services what we offer
we have design here must some lines
about your digital marketing and I am
thinking there is also
uh one part which I cut down
not something charging these mistake it
was mine because I stopped generating
the response
okay
really good let's copy this text now and
paste it under
and let's change this and paste it
let's check it this time
so
this is how this one is looking now
this is also really looking
very we can decrease the size of this
image do not worry about that
this is the service our services and
some junk data here we can write this
website is providing this and that okay
service one that we provide this service
we provide this service and we provide
this service okay this is all about that
right really very good
really very good
it's really really good
okay you can change everything from it
customize it on our are these thing
let's just go back okay
this one is looking good okay now
let's ask jrgb to create the about page
for us so we'll write create
so I think
um meanwhile it's writing the code for
us I wanted to tell you that chat is
great from for everyone but as I know
the code how this code is working I know
what is section what is their class and
what are the function in this grid
system that's using max weight it's
using the Excel function I know
everything about it and if you are a
fresher or you don't know about anything
about the coding uh I think you should
first know about the language or the
framework then only ask this to charge
DBT or take help from the charity
meeting right if you don't know about
the language or the framework and you'll
just tell your activity to create this
and this for us it's easy it will create
for you but it will not
help you in your future
so according to me just
yeah
use it to learn not to
work okay
so
let's move ahead
and the path is given
okay
it was again managed oh let's ask it
again
responsive
about
section
using
table
okay I just based on but it
is very intelligent
I misspell the Elven spelling and then
it corrected it
very good
so this is not the complete code for the
about page I'll ask to
and T and then it will take this command
or not
right right so let's see
after this about section we'll create
this contact page and then we'll
find this website right
so this is really really helpful for the
developers I must say
so
let's copy this and
code and paste it under this
section
okay
this is how the about page is looking
really very good the images sizes 500
into 500 it's really really big so we
can change the size of the image
let's see
that is that
at 250
to 50
and then it will not come again
let's just delete the source
of in the unsplash
for the random image
right
that command is really useful
okay to add that yeah
Ninja
this is how like this about is looking
really really good guys really very good
if I tell a charge if you need to create
this on the right side or this image I
want on the left hand side or right hand
side it will definitely look for us as I
have given him the uh task in this
section information section it
definitely worked
so I must say it's really very good
so
now let's move on to the
contact page okay
let's here right create
a responsive
contact
section
using
Railway
and I'll ask him to to add some sections
for us so let's see whether it can take
up that or not
okay and let's view it in a second shot
let's first see how is the contact
Section is looking then we'll tell him
to embrow is that
so it's just taking a section class
inside that section class it's using
some classes which is legs wrap and all
and it's giving us
it's really important
let's copy this text again and paste it
here
so the contact us is also looking very
good get in touch and then it will
redirect us to the
that really would really
the images sizes are
[Music]
large but we can reduce it it's not a
big deal but it's all looking very good
right
so one thing is left is the footer part
let's ask it to create a filter for us
no
okay this is the last and final step for
this
create
so put the
section
using
and
thank you
this is really very good looking very
good let's add the
splash
and then
use it here
so this is
how
it's looking down
so overall if I see it really given us a
good good output really
so I will say charge GPT can only help
us that's it
as this code that is created by charity
for us we can't use it directly this
structure that charity created for us is
good but we need to add so many things
before deploying it right if I'll see
this one we need to add this services in
the center and we need to uh
arrange the text and the services we
need to change the size of the services
if the client wants it
horizontally then we have to change that
we need to change this image size as in
front of you I change this email address
I use the different apis
so overall it's very good but there are
so many things that we have to do okay
and for that developers are needed as
technology advances in all aspects of
Our Lives programming has become
increasingly important it is used in
many fields and industries including
software development gaming and
entertainment education scientific
research web development and many more
so needless to say the demand for
programming and coding in the IT
industry will probably keep increasing
for the foreseeable future but where
does charity PT open ai's popular
language model fall in this chain that's
exactly what we are focusing on in this
today's video on that note welcome to
the simply learn YouTube channel today
we are here with an interesting video on
chat Deputy for programming
scientificity is after all a product of
artificial intelligence if if you want
to know more about artificial
intelligence and become an expert in the
field of AI consider the artificial
intelligence engineer master program by
simply learn and master those necessary
skills check out the link in the
description for more details as I said
earlier programming is utilized in many
domains like web development robotics
mobile development machine learning and
so on so how can a program achieve
maximum code efficiency nowadays we have
EI based tools like chargeability to
make our programming experience more
efficient although there are several
coding resources platforms such as stack
Overflow and GitHub where programmers
can find solutions to their technical
programming questions charging stands
out from the competition because of its
quick response time usability and
support for numerous languages among
many other benefits now let's first
discuss how chat GPT Works charging
generates responses to the text input
using a method called Transformer
architecture a large volume of text is
fed into the chat GPT from various
sources including books website and
other social media platforms the model
then uses this information to forecast
the following word in a phrase based on
the words that came before it the chat
Deputy systems allows users to enter
text or queries and then the system uses
its training data and algorithms to
produce the right answer the answer is
created after the input text has been
examined and the pattern most likely to
match the input have been identified
using the training data in short charge
APD is designed to respond to queries
logically and command more quickly and
accurately but why do programmers use
chargeability on a regular basis
chargeability assist programmers by
offering programming related answers and
solutions and helping them improve their
skills beside that charge Equity is
utilized for code generation code
completion code review and a natural
language interface let us understand
each in detail charge is trained to
generate the code or even the entire
program described in the natural
language specified by what they want a
program to do and then charge video
could generate the relevant look at the
example of how chargpt generates the
code so now open the chargpt and you can
type any program that you want rgbt to
generate so I will give write a parallel
program in Java so here you can type
write a
palindrome
program in Java
so using Java programming language it
should generate the whole program
so as you can see it has generated the
program so it has used a class name
called palindrome Checker and it has
used each palindrome as a method name
and also it will give the explanation on
the program so you can see here why it
is explaining why each palindrome is
used as a method and it also explains
the for Loop if
a condition and so on next we have code
completion chargeable is trained to
generate Snippets of code or even fully
fledged programs it can generate a list
of possible code completion depending on
the context of the user's incomplete
piece of Code by automatically producing
the entire code it can help the
developers save time and minimize errors
next let's see the example of code
completion using chatibility so even if
the program is explained in natural
language chargpt will generate the
proper code and give the complete code
so let's type here
using a function
write a program
to convert
the string
in uppercase
so using which language let's keep using
C programming
and enter it once again
so as you can see we have just said that
using a function write a program to
convert the string in uppercase so using
C programming language and using C
programming language it has used
function and you know this is the
function convert to uppercase and has
come given the complete code for string
to convert a string in uppercase and
also it gave the explanation here the
convert to uppercase function takes a
pointer to a string as its argument and
then iterates over each character in the
string using a for Loop so it explained
why for Loop is used why two upper is
used and why the method convert to
uppercase is used everything
so let's say we'll give one piece of
code like void
to Upper
care
Str
so as you can see we just gave the
method to Upper and it's generating the
complete code
so this is how chargedipity works for
code completion next code review
chargedy can analyze code identify the
box or errors in the program and further
help resolve them it allows developers
to fix errors more quickly so now let's
have a look at the example of code
review so in this example chat Deputy
will review the code so even if the code
has some mistake it will give the proper
output let's say we have given the
example here
so we gave
the function or a method called upper
and here we are giving
the keyword called upward so you should
check whether this piece of code is
proper or is there any mistake in this
so as I said
uh it's saying that the given code
appears to have logical error as a
function upper is being called
recursively on itself inside the loop
so instead of giving two upper we just
gave upper here right so using the
keyword to Upper only then this string
can be converted to uppercase so here we
gave just upper so it says that it is
having this piece of code is having a
logical error and it gives a proper code
for us
so I hope it's clear
and then we have natural language
interface with the use of chargepity a
software application can be given a
natural language user interface that
enables users to communicate with it
through natural language instructions
rather than through conventional user
interfaces next let's see how chargity
helps the programmers for natural
language interface so let's say we'll
give here
create
a software application
where
the user
asked to enter
credential
for the to-do app
enter
so as you can see
the charge video will give the steps so
it can provide you with an outlet for
creating a software applications that
requires the user to enter credential
for a to-do app so here it is few steps
that we need to follow to do a to-do app
so it's giving the explanation step by
step
so it says that determine the
programming language and framework then
set up the database to store the user
information and then create the
registration page and then finally
create the login page as well and once
the user is successfully logged in
um you know it will have the options
like add edit and delete task as well
and then finally implement the security
measures to you know protect your
passwords and then test the application
to ensure that it works as intended and
the user data is being stored and
retrieved correctly so it gives the
steps of how it has to be developed
enhance your professional prospects
through enrollment and postgraduate
program in Ai and machine learning from
Simply learn one year of experience is
preferred to enroll in this course hurry
up and enroll Now find the course Link
in the description box I'm sure you all
are aware of charge Deputy at this point
the Revolutionary new AI based chatbot
developed by open AI have taken the
World by storm
thanks to its near lifelike responses
and a very intricate pattern of answers
we have never seen this level of
expertise from a chatbot before which
really made us think to what extent can
we push it there are many questions on
lead code that even the most experienced
programmers have difficulty answering so
we wanted to see how far charge GPT can
take us have we finally reached the
stage where AI is going to replace us
let's find out so basically here we will
be listing 10 really difficult questions
that we found on lead code popularly
asked while hiring and other Superior
examinations and see if charge GPD can
actually answer or solve those difficult
questions or not but before you like to
watch more such interesting videos then
do subscribe to our YouTube channel and
hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply learn so let's get
started so here is the lead code let's
see uh in our list which is the first
question that we are going to implement
in our chat GPD and see if it's able to
solve it or not
mainly we'll focus on hard category
questions only so
according to my research there's a
question of median
of two sorted arrays
so as you can see the success rate is
35.7 so let's see the chart GPT is able
to do this question so first let us go
through the question
okay
press enter let's see what it first
returns
uh on a one approach to solving this
problem is to use a modified binary
search algorithm to find the median of
the two sorted arrays so right now it's
particularly giving the logic which we
can actually imply to solve this
question
and this is a good thing for the charge
GPD is that before uh giving the code
it's actually explaining how they are
putting the logic in together in the
code
so probably you can use this logic to
create your own program but let's see
how sensible this code is
vital any program
is in Python so if you are looking for
your Solutions on chat GPD you can
always opt out or you know mention the
specific program you want the code in
so okay it's it's also gives that okay
that the time complexity will be o log
Min m or n so let's see if it
the case or not
so we have copied it and we quickly
paste it over here
as you can see
uh as we know that python is uh very
sensitive towards its uh
syntax and you can see the indentation
over here is perfect but here it's not
so I feel that something like this is
something with lead code
so let me just quickly Rectify this so
you can see I have cleared out the
indentation issue and let's just quickly
run this program so that we can get an
idea if this is the correct program
uh now you can see here we have an error
let's see copy this and see what charge
GPD has to say for this
so if you remember when we actually saw
this question there were three arguments
passed through this function which was
self nums 1 and nums two ask GPT if it
can write the code with self-argument
and see if it's correct
and read that if it can pass a
self-argument through that function and
see if it can generate a new code
okay now it has cleared that yes it
takes three arguments
let's
copy this code
put it over here again I think we will
have to go through the indentation
process
oh no this time it's fine okay so now
quickly run this program let's see if
this time it passes all the test cases
or not
okay
I think it doesn't need because the
class is already mentioned over here
uh
yeah
okay the runtime is 35 Ms and as you can
see case 1 and case two is definitely
passed
so let us see if
the code can pass all the test cases
internally mentioned in this question
now you can see the first three cases
are actually accepted but the other
three are not there is a runtime error
so
the first question in our list chat GPT
was unable to solve let's move on to our
next question
others zigzag conversion
now let me quickly search for it
this is a question here also you can see
the success rate is definitely below 50
and the difficulty level is medium so
the hard one charge BD was not able to
solve let's see if this can be done
shin so it will give a string that will
be written in a zigzag pattern on a
given number of rows
and then you have to read the line in a
certain
as you can see over here
we have to write the code that will take
a string and make this conversion given
in a number of row
has also means a certain amount of
certificate repeat that's also given a
certain specifications that we exactly
want so this time we'll make sure that
we are mentioning everything
so let's quickly copy this
here
okay now that we have mentioned all the
specifications
uh let me quickly
feed
for you
feed and pasted now let's see what code
it has to generate
it's implementing the code in C plus
plus so meanwhile it's generating the
code let's quickly
like the code or it's already C plus
plus okay
okay it's also suggesting that we can
definitely use Python and Java
and it's generating an alternative code
as well for us
that's Sharp
just quickly copy this code
and
see
the one I think it's uh okay so it's
generating in uh
Java
let's generating we'll definitely have a
look at its alternative codes as well
let's quickly have a look at what it has
to C plus plus one the first code
generated by it
uh is correct or not
okay copy the code
paste it over here
together
dilation error
okay okay
so let's do this later
the one thing
definitely this time we have mentioned
all the constraints criteria
specifications that we wanted in a code
but again
judging
questions we have implemented till now
let's see if it has any success rate in
further
okay it seems okay
now it is okay so this time it is uh
generating the solution
considering the error in Java
see what it has to say in Java and we'll
make it specific that the error was in C
plus plus program so generates the
correct code
plus plus program
what it has to say
oh those things
so this error is something related to
the compiler and now it is giving the
updated code in C plus plus
is the correct one or not
should apologizing for making arrows in
their Solutions
quite fascinating
[Music]
um
paste the code over here I don't see
there's a lot of difference or changes
over here let's see if it runs or not
let me see if all the braces are covered
over here or not
I think it's missing a brace
okay so there was a syntax error one
brace was missing
um I don't
for that
definitely something with the code but
okay we can give that to charge GPT it
was partially read codes issue because
we were copying reports till it was not
giving the error that there is a breeze
missing
has passed the first three cases
mentioned over here and the run time is
3M is now just let us submit this code
and see if it passes all the rest of the
cases or not minded this time we have
actually mentioned all the constraints
so let's see if this has to in two
okay so this time it has passed all the
test cases but still my conclusion with
this question is
uh it was still not able to generate the
solution in one go
uh but so I can give that to charge GPT
because the first error that we faced
was more of a lead coaches issue
because it was something with company
and chatgpt was able to give a proper
oh now let's go back to our problems
list
so
right now the score is one and one it
was unable to solve one question and one
not
so let's have a look at the third
question and see if that brings any
difference to the charge equities
scoreboard right now or not
third question that we are going to deal
with is substring
with
concatenation of all words
this is in the category again and the
success success rate is 31.1 percent
which is even lesser than the first
question that we faced which was median
of the two sorted Aries
we're trying here we are actually trying
to cover all the Spectra the huge
Spectra of different types of
questions and you know categories
available in coding and to give you an
idea of how
beneficial charging can be for you to
solve difficult questions which can be
helpful for your interview base in
companies or you can say well
established companies among companies
so here this video is specifically for
you to give an idea that whether you can
use it for your benefit and you know to
get an idea or you can actually
compare it with
your
subjects uh and you can get a you know
wider range of different types of
approaches to a certain question
so let's start with the third question
is that you're given a string and then
array of strings probably words and all
the strings or words are of the same
length now a concatenated substring in s
is a substring that contains all the
strings of any permutation of words
concatenated
here you can see it's given an example
that if words has a b c d e f then a b c
d e f basically uh has done all the
permutation and combinations that can be
done using that
there's a big added
uh
Vision that AC d b e f is not a
concatenated substring because it is not
the concatenation of any permutation of
words
so we have to basically return the
starting indices of all the concatenated
substring in the S string
also you can choose any order for it
here it has also given a
two examples for you to
understand the question in a better
perspective
now
really a copy this question and see if
what programming language algebra
chooses to answer this time
uh to a new chat again
be these constraints
okay it's just a question
okay
this is the solution that we're getting
right now you requested a model that is
not compatible with this engine please
contact us through our help center at
help
dot openai.com for further questions let
me just quickly refresh it if it has a
something to do with the you know demand
also sometimes it happens that the
console is very busy and you're unable
to implement
uh your task in it so again let's
quickly
paste it over here
that we want a code write a code
to return now
let's enter
the same definitely it's not giving the
same error
let's see it this time at charger PD has
anything to give as a solution
okay so it's generating the code in
Python
the more thing every time charge APD
doesn't follows a similar pattern as you
can see in the first question it
explained the logic first and then
implemented the code second time it just
gave you the approach not the logic and
then implemented the code in multiple
languages uh first choosing for C plus
plus
and this time it's straight away wind
for the code so definitely we can say
that it has some different styles of
generating their code and explaining the
code I think it depends on the
understanding how they want the code to
be presented in front of the user and to
give the perspective that if the code is
understandable or not and if the code
has multiple approaches I think charge
if it is capable to capable enough to
give that
that the code is generated let's quickly
copy it
and
paste it over here
I feel the indentation issue is going to
be there
it was not there okay
F probably I think if we backspace
let me quickly Rectify this and I'll
do once the indentations are
but
the indentation is corrected now let's
have a look
at the Gold if it's correct or not let's
quickly run it
definitely it has a given our first
syntax error again
I can see that even a specific video
question it definitely goes to at least
one error which is mainly the syntax one
sure if that is something with the lead
code or you know with the
charge GPT code generation
okay
all right we have given the error okay
it seems that the error is caused by the
use of type hints the function type and
so introduced the version we are using
is lower than that okay so basically
it's generating now in the python
version uh probably this code is
well suited for different version of
python let's change it then and see if
that helps
on it
is actually generating the code
okay again
given the other one I think it's again
something with the self
uh
I didn't want the new code generated is
here
will definitely come back to that error
and have a look at the Python 3 code
also
uh first let's copy this code
and
in giving the same error
and see what it has to say
uh you know every time the charge APD
generates the python code we cannot
ever takes self as an argument but
as you can see when we start the code
it's already mentioned what arguments we
need to pass from
a particular function so I think that is
something with the lead code so
that what all arguments it's passing
even though we have mentioned everything
this time we have mentioned all the
constraints we have mentioned all the
necessary
specifications that we want in the code
even then the code is not correct and
the one goal so probably I'll get this
point to GPT it's something with the
lead code because it's passing that
parameter and everything we have to
mention that parameter pretty much when
we do the chargeability is able to solve
the question so let's see well let me
actually mention that
because self parameter self argument
from that parameters I'm gonna make it
one of the parameters
processing that
yes self can be passed as the first
argument to the given function now let's
see if that it's able to give the
correct solution or not again we can see
it's uh generating the code and you know
Python 3
but we can give that to charge GPD that
either it uses python or Python 3 the
error is with the self argument
so once we mentioned that error and when
we mention that specification that if
charge if it can pass self argument
through that particular function in that
code the solution is pretty much
right so here it's also implementing and
giving the answer
okay it also has mentioned that it's
important to mention import important
list and counter so
okay
just copy this because again there will
be a lot of uh inpatient issues
okay now that we have it
copy the code
I was already mentioned so we will
copy it from the function
paste it
run this code and see if it has
the solution in it or not
yeah there's an indentation issue
let me
again as you can see it is able to pass
all the test cases here and the run time
is 28 MS
now let us submit this question and see
if it is able to pass other test cases
or not
accepted
so it is able to pass all the test cases
and I think this is something with lead
code again uh whenever we are generating
the python code we are actually passing
self argument uh in lead code but charge
GPD is not assuming it so this solution
is definitely correct
even though we are specifying everything
we will have to be more specific that we
have to run one more argument uh from
the function so that it you know
generates the solution in one go so let
us uh try that in our next question
but we can definitely see charge APD was
able to solve this so now the scoreboard
is two one one uh among three questions
it is definitely able to solve two
questions even the first question it was
able to generate a correct solution but
it was not that accurate to pass all the
test cases
to a question list
the next question that we are going to
cover is in Queens
category but still the success rate is
63 over here again a new genre or
question we are covering over here let
us see it
solve it or not definitely the success
rate shows that many people are able to
do it definitely more than half of
people who have attempted it so see if
the question can
this AI can beat that or not
so I have to copy this question this
question mentions that the end Queens
puzzle is the problem of placing n
Queens on an N into N Chess board such
that no to Queens attack each other
given an integer n return all distinct
solutions to the end Queen puzzle
so basically n is any given number and
you have to create a puzzle of end in
and you have to arrange all the Queens
in such uh you know way also the number
of Queens in the board will be equal to
the number
in and in such a way that it is not able
to attack each other in any case
corporate this part of the question
and the constraint is
just one let me
that it will be easy to keep a track of
what all questions charity is able to
solve
so these questions are very popular uh
in interviews uh whenever you actually
go to technical rounds and for
prestigious companies these questions
are very popular uh they are considered
as very uh suitable questions to check
to check your you know IQ and to check
your potential that how well aware you
are towards your coding potential
now we have pressed enter it is giving
the logic it is going to implement in
its code one approach to solve the end
Queens puzzle is to use backtracking
ideas to start by placing a queen in the
First Column of the first row so let's
see if the codes
again capable to you know
solve it or not
again it's giving the python code
generating the code let us quickly see
whether it's python or Python 3
written python 3.
okay
once the code is generated I'll also
write that you need to pass one more
argument from the main function
uh that is self and let let it generate
the code again and see that code can run
in one go or not
should what I want and let the C sure
here's an example of how you can pass an
additional parameter self let's see if
it suits
the code or not
from the 12 and queen function is a
method of the end Queens class and it
takes self as its first parameter
followed by the integer n so yes this
solution does take self as a parameter
so let's see if this can
run in one go or not because this time
we have already covered the most uh
frequently generated error which is
syntax error of not mentioning parameter
self
certainly
let me see the indentation if it's
correct or not
this time uh let us quickly run this
class
okay there you go now you can see that
it has actually run the code in one go
and all the test cases are passed in one
go even the runtime is 39 Ms so
definitely charge gbt is able to provide
the solutions the Logics in a proper
manner it's just that we have to be more
specific with what we want exactly from
chat GPT right now we can see that it
has been able to successfully generate 4
out of five uh questions that we have
actually implemented till now out of
which four are from hard category
let us submit this code and see if it
also covers all the test cases
internally fed in for this question just
a second I think I will have to submit
it again
thank you cool it has accepted all the
test cases and this question is done by
child GPT it has actually implemented
this question that we are going to cover
till now I can say charge gbd has taken
the lead it is pretty much able to
implement all the questions uh I think
there are still some range of questions
that it is not able to implement as we
saw the first one was not a huge success
but um I can still give that to charge
upd as it is in Ai and still in a you
know developing mode but still if it can
give you 90 of the output correct it is
a pretty decent and you know amazing
thing to do
question is shortest sabare with some at
least K now let me search
for it
again this question is from hard
category and its success rate is even
low which is 26.1 let's see this
question can be solved by chart GPT
let's have a look at the question given
an integer ad in nums and an integer K
return the length of the shortest non
empty sub array of nums with the sum of
at least K so if there is no such
stability return minus 1.
so
the battery is a contagious part of an
array it has also given a description of
what an array is or what sub array is
so now that we have
written a new chat
and let me
explains
so here is one way to solve the problem
initialize two pointers uh left and
right both pointing to the first element
of the array initialize a variable so
now this time this it is giving pointers
to solve this question uh you know a
perfect approach in a sequential manner
so that you can also use these pointers
and the Logics it's giving to actually
Implement your own code apart from you
know asking it to generate a code
so I can see that it has given the
pointers but not the code
specific
so yes it's giving an implementation of
the algorithm in Python uh again we can
see it's not the Python 3 it's python uh
little lower version of python
um
50.
which do
python
then we have to pass self
so it has generated code and explain
what all variables and what will
statements have the individual
functionality as so we have also asked
it to pass self parameter through its
function and then write the code so
let's see if it adheres to it and
generates new code with self parameter
okay so here
is the new code with self parameter
passed through the main function
now I do have confidence on chat GPT
till now that it was able to generate
logical and you know
pretty much decent solutions for every
question
the spouse to the class as an argument
when an object is created and is stored
as an instance variable the shortest sub
array takes K as an argument which is
the target sum so basically it's trying
to explain the code at what exactly it's
doing and what individual statements
have as an influence on the code
and whatever parameters they are passing
what influence or what position they
hold in the code
so definitely charge APD is not just
generating the code uh you know it's
also explaining the logic and approaches
towards it
and when it's generating the code as you
can see here they have legit explain the
whole code how it's actually functioning
that's a good way to you know put
emphasis on you know put a confidence on
the solution
remove this
I better okay
okay so it's apologizing it made a
mistake in its previous response the
init method should take two arguments
one for the nums array and one for key
so now it's again generating a new code
or adhering to the syntax error or type
error generated
right or not
I've mentioned that here direct weather
takes two arguments one for the nums
array and one for the K which was the
error exactly
and it's again explaining the whole code
so that one person who watches code or
you know logic could understand the
functionality of it
let's say this code can run
food
checking for indentation removing class
and run
this one more type error
let's copy it and
I will be mentioned that we want
self-argument to be passed
it is still not able to generate
you know the correct solution twice
so let's see this time it can work out
issue though with the code
apologize for the confusion seems that I
misunderstood
that you are trying to call the function
directly without creating an instance of
the class and that
function outside of the class and simply
Call It by passing the parameters like
this okay the code is definitely
generated by itself so definitely I am
not calling any function uh
the code I copied was actually generated
by charging itself so it's contradicting
its own pointers Maybe
right we have copied the question uh
sorry the code
let's paste it
again look for indentation
and run this code
okay once again it is not able to you
know
us
time error is there and now again we
have to copy this error and paste it
again according to chat GPD it was
confused with the context of the
question
uh like I said the code was anyway
generated by Char GPT so yeah
this time I think GPT is trying to
contradict its own logics
let's see if the current code can do the
miracle of solving this question
last
and run
okay so after four attempts of running
the codes generated by charge GPD on
delete code but this particular question
finally now it's able to pass all the
test cases so
I can I have a very contradicting point
right now uh
not exactly contradicting more of a
skepticism that okay Chad Jeopardy does
generate a proper code or logic but it
doesn't considers all the criterias or
it also has a tendency of taking the
question in a wrong context
so I feel that when we as a human try to
solve these questions we definitely try
to implement all the Logics and if we
get it we can actually get the code in
one go
magic or you know demand of the question
and be AI being Superior version or you
know trying to be the superior version
of human brain and going to the extents
of a human brain
still faces those issues
can be uh you know drawback for chat GPT
because you can see for this specific
question we have face multiple types of
error and we have seen charging pretty
contradicting its own prior code
so
definitely this is something to consider
or you know something to think about
submit this code
you can have like I said after giving
four attempts it is still not able to
pass all the test cases it is only able
to six pass 61 out of 97 test cases
which is almost 70 percent of the test
cases 30k percent of this test cases are
still not passed even though we
mentioned all the constraints we have
mentioned the comments we have mentioned
all the errors that but this particular
code can go through
still it was not able to generate the
proper code that could go through all
the test cases
so
this was a fail for chart GPT uh at
least till now we have made out this
point that chargpt is definitely not
able to solve every question
array with same average
for it
array with
this is from the category of hard
questions and the success rate is only
25 percent
Let me refresh it and remove this code
now let's have a look at the code what
it demands so you are given an integer
Harry nums now you should move each
element of nums into one of two arrays e
and B S and B are non-empty and the
average of array a is equal to average
of array B
or return true if it is possible to
achieve that
condition is not justified
so given a note that for an array uh
average array is the sum of all the
elements of array over the length of
array okay so it is giving the lodge of
how to actually you know find out the
average of what average is exactly
and also it has given a few examples to
give you how the code needs to be
projected or implemented
please copy the code and paste it
okay it is possible to achieve this by
checking all the possible subsets of the
nums array and comparing the averages of
the subsets so definitely it has given
you the approach uh the way you can
actually think of solving this question
however this approach would have a Time
complexity so it's also giving that this
approach can have a Time complexity of O
to the power n so again it's suggesting
a different approach a more efficient
approach that will be using dynamic
programming now that can be used to find
the subsets with a specific average and
create a 2d array with the length of I
and J which that will be the length of
the two
we have actually given as input and
represents whether or not it is possible
to get a sum of J using the first
means of the nums array
so
[Music]
so the time complexity of this approach
would be o and S so definitely is not
given a code let me ask for it
not for every question chart GPD is
generating a code it is also mentioning
just and the approaches that we can
actually use uh definitely again we will
have to mention that what we want from
them
as you can see I've mentioned this time
to write a code for it and now it's
generating a new code for it
also mentioning comments that what every
snippet of the code is actually for and
what it will do like here you can see it
will fill the 2dr ADP uh DP stands for
dynamic programming this here it has
mentioned initialized the First Column
as true so it is also mentioning the
comments for better idea of you know
understanding the code in a better way
it's also giving the note that this
implementation assumes that the nums
array is non-empty and that the elements
of the numzare are non-negative integers
okay also the above implementation will
return the possible subset that can be
formed by the array to fulfill the given
condition and not pulling true and false
but that's what we want exactly right
uh still okay let us
this approach is in Python so let's copy
this and
see this code can run or not
I can clearly see that again it needs to
pass self
uh
parameter
indentation
and
foreign
specifically
uh
sure here is an example of how you can
pass the self parameter so now the
current solution will pass self
okay
rate represent here okay
and it has generated a new code uh
considering the
criteria I just mentioned that I need
self parameter to be passed through the
function can partnership
so I have copied it and let's quickly
paste it over here
uh you know pass
all the cases are not wait uh we need to
remove this
okay it's done now quickly just run this
program
okay so here is uh
error attribute error solution object
has no attribute okay so let me copy it
and paste it over here and see what Char
GPT has to say about this error
okay the error message solution object
has no attribute
uh split array same average suggests
that there is no method named with this
in the solution class so it is likely
that the test case is trying to call
this method but it does not exist in
your implementation anyway that I have
not mentioned this method this was given
by charity itself so again we can see
the condition that it is contradicting
its own so again it has generated new
response and it says that it should
resolve the issue and the test case
should be able to call this particular
method correctly
so that is something for us to decide
now let us copy this code and see that
now is it able to run or not and pass
all these test cases or not
and click on run
okay now the new generated response it
does works for this particular question
and the runtime is 12 Ms and it
trespasses the first two cases mentioned
so let us quickly submit this code and
see if the code is perfectly you know
fine to deal with all the test cases
actually fed by lead code
okay now again we can see one more
situation that this code is not able to
pass all the test cases even though we
mentioned all the specifications
constraints and we were pretty precise
about the questions and parameters that
we want our code to be done in certain
form but still it is just able to pass
68 test cases out of 111 which is almost
50 to 60 percent of uh total amount of
test cases
so let's move on to the next question
that is find substring with given hash
value so let me quickly search for this
question
find substring
with
which value again it's
it's a question from hard category and
the success rate is
22.2 percent so let's have a look at the
question what it demands so here the
hash of a zero indexed string of length
K given integers P and M is computed
using the following functions now hash
with parameters SPM
uh this is the logic given how we want
our output to be demonstrated in certain
value or how the hash can be generated
the particular formula uh how you can
get the hash value of your you know
string
so the question is you are given a
string and then teachers
and you have to return the first
substring of that string of length uh
given to you here it's K the test cases
will be generated such that and answer
always exists we are going to copy this
course and mention all the
specifications mentioned here in their
charging pre console so that it gets
all the specifications
open the code and
so I have copied the code and I'll paste
it over here now let's check for
indentation it's fine let's remove class
my class
and
my dad faces a type error so let's move
on to the next question again we saw
that charging but he was not able to
solve this particular question coming
back to our list the next question in
the list that we are going to cover is
partition array into two arrays to
minimize some difference let's quickly
search for that question
I want to shouldn't add a
to
two arrays
again this question is from hard
category and the success rate is even
more low so let's have a look at the
question first it's partition array into
two arrays to minimize some difference
that is generated as the output
or we can see that there are three
constraints so now quickly we'll copy
this question and see if it is able to
solve this question or not first we have
to create a new shot
I'll be
all the constraints
let's see what charging but he has to
say for this particular question
let's
ask it to generate a code this time it
has only generated a logic not exactly
Logic the approach indeed they are going
to follow or anyone can follow to solve
this question
let me ask if it can generate a code
okay it's definitely taking longer time
to generate this code
okay here is the code which is possible
python implementation and
[Music]
okay the code is generated and it's
mentioning that the code takes in an
input an array of integer called nums so
basically uh it's explaining that what
it actually is doing which is pretty
much explained in the question itself
that what exactly it needs to function
like and what will be the variables and
what will be the inputs and how it needs
to be segregated to uh obtain our
Optimum result
so
let's copy this
and
paste it over here again like I said we
can see that it's generating you know uh
again we could see that
past self parameter
okay
attribute error let's quickly copy it
paste it over here
see what Char GPD has to say about it
okay
that you have seen that after placing
the error it's giving that error message
you're seeing suggest that there's a
problem with the function name in your
code so the error message is indicating
that there is no function called minimum
difference within the solution uh also I
have seen that apart from the function
name it doesn't have a self parameter so
let me just write it down
argument
apps let me copy it that will be better
and write the
new code with it
let me see if it can generate a new code
this time
so yeah it has agreed sure there is an
example and here's the code
I have copied this
and
paste it over
here
see any such huge difference in the
syntax or the logic of the code
but yeah we can definitely think of
running now
let's run this code
we copy it and paste it over here again
an error has prompted out I
don't know how valid
code will get after projecting this
error over here in charge GPD
so yeah definitely considering the error
message you are seeing is indicated that
the function is returning INF which is
not a valid value for the expected
return type integer
so in the base case where I and J are
both 0 the value of is set to float
which is positively Infinity however the
expected output is an integer so this
valid this value is not valid so again
considering this change the charge every
is giving a new code so let us see how
valid this new code is
okay I can see that it has changed the
logic over here instead of float INF it
has changed but it has uh written a new
syntax a new logic over there now and
also medical guarantees that this may
solve the issue returning INF as the
value let's see how accurate charge GPT
here is
now okay we have pasted the logic
uh yeah as
oh okay sorry I need to remove these two
lines
now let's quickly run this program
okay so now as you can see it could only
pass one test case
but not the first two so there's no
point of submitting this code as we can
see that the logic for the score or this
code and as a whole is not
well moving on
next in the list we have is
longest common subpar now let's see
longest
common
subpath
so this question also comes from
category of hard questions and the
success rate is 27 now let's see what
this question demands actually now let's
quickly copy this question with all the
constraints and whatever apart from
example is left on the screen we need to
copy it as you can see over here you can
not just miss out on any specifications
looking for the constraints copy
and paste now enter
giving the approach to solve this
question which is dynamic programming
approach okay we didn't want any code
over here so let's try
that if it can present a code
because I have asked to write a code for
this and yes charge GPT has definitely
agreed to provide me a code for it uh
charging is done with its explanations
I'll type it out and wait for the new
code which will contain self as a
parameter that it's the score is pretty
similar to the previous one it's just
that it's using the self argument the
function as it was mentioned by me
so let's quickly copy this code
paste it over here
check for the indentation
we run this code
okay I spoke too fast here we have
another error let's see what charging
has to say about this
okay the list index out of range error
is likely occurring on line 10 because
the indices I and J are being properly
bounds checked before being used to
access elements in the path and TP
arrays okay so we have found a new code
let's quickly copy this code and see if
this code is capable of you know
eliminating the errors we
probably found
click copy and paste
let me check correlation
done and run
then we got a error over here even
though after providing so many
specifications and criterias and errors
and conditions yet chargium is not able
to provide a perfect solution for the
code
uh moving on to the last question of our
list
that is going to be uh sum of total
strength of wizards hopefully this
question does from married for child GPT
and prove itself lucky which rgbt graph
for this video because for now we can
see it's a 50 50 scene uh half of the
question charging was able to provide
Solutions with and half other questions
charging Beauty couldn't actually figure
out what
needs to be done even the logic and
approach was correct still the
implementation of the code was not
correct
so let me search for this
question some of total
trend of wizards again a hard category
question so let's have a look at the
question first
let's click copy this question
create a new chat
paste it over here
and
look for constraints now that we have
copied it pasted and enter
foreign
how you can actually think of a solution
for this particular question charge
ability has not generated any code uh
let me ask for it
okay
so here's an example again they have
implemented the code in Python now it is
also giving a note that the approach is
valid only if you're allowed to modify
the original array and also we are not
working on down over
function and then write this
code so let's see if we can do it with
self argument
okay so yeah there's an example it's
generating the code
okay so let's see
what's the update with the code
here
this
episode are
let's add
solution
and run the code
so there's a runtime error let me see
why
okay
this error
and paste it over here
your charger body have to say
the error message solution object has no
attribute mode suggest that there is a
class name solution and the code is
trying to access an attribute named mod
on an instance of that class with
attribute doesn't exist we probably need
to make more specifications and if it
still doesn't works then it clearly
classifies that charge GPD doesn't takes
every point or a classification uh you
know in consideration which ultimately
uh
you know reflects on the solution
the new code is here let me quickly
paste it
by running this code let's see if this
works
try running it again
it has a runtime error was unable to
solve one more question now that we have
tried and tested a huge spectrum of
questions from Lead Core on charge GPT
we can conclude that though charge APD
is an amazing tool with the bright
future it's has its own limitations and
maybe it is not ready to replace humans
or compete with human brains these
questions were picked from a list of
frequently asked questions for
interviews and examinations Chad GPT
does have a potential to generate Logics
and approaches for the code in an
effective manner but still its ability
to analyze the question is weak as
compared to humans as we know these
questions are there the success rate
thus shows that a proper solution to
exist for these questions but still even
after multiple attempts chargedy was not
able to find the correct answer but we
can also give charging the benefit of
doubt that it's still it's in its
initial phase and still there are a lot
of aspects that need to be worked on so
probably in future charge GPT can take
an upper hand over this but for now
charging needs to do a lot of work for
these situations enhance your
professional prospects through
enrollment in postgraduate program in Ai
and machine learning from Simply learn
one year of experience is preferred to
enroll in this course hurry up and
enroll Now find the course Link in the
description box and moving on we will
start with our project
and for that first we'll create a folder
in Python projects
and name index
Telegram
Port using shared gbd
okay and inside this we'll open the
command prompt
and open our
ID that is I would be using the visual
studio code and you can use any ID that
you have hands on
and now
we will go back to our chat GPT
and we'll start here but before that
let's talk about telegram board
so a telegram brought is a program that
interacts with users via the telegram
messaging app uh the pretty quiz it is
you should have a telegram account
and Boards can be used for a wide range
of purposes such as customer support
news delivery and even games
and chat Jeopardy so charity is a large
language model trained by open AI that
is based on gbt 3.5 architecture and
creativity is capable of generating
human-like response through text based
inputs making it a great tool for
building chat boards
and now if we talk about prerequisites
you should have a telegram account
python installed on your system and we
need a python telegram board library
that I will show you what to install and
that charge APD will tell us equal to
install
so we'll just ask chat Jeopardy
to create
telegram board
using
python
okay so it says error we'll just refresh
the page
ask again create telegram board
using python okay
I will see what
instance so Creator telegram board you
need a telegram
mode token to the board father yeah we
have to go to the board color I will
show you guys how to do that
install the required libraries next we
need to install
okay and write this code
okay
so in this script
they have started with the start
function so
it will just says hello
when it will be started
okay
so we'll add some more functionalities
and
we will ask where to find the
your API token here so I know like we
have to go to the
portfather but we will ask charity video
also
we can we find
the
repeat open
so it states that to get to telegram
about API token you need to create a new
bot by talking to the board father on
Telegram
open telegram and search for board
father okay and send the board further
message that is Slash new mode and the
board father will ask you for the name
of the board and
it will ask you about the username and
if it is the word father will then
generate a token for your board this
token is a string of characters that
uniquely identifies your board on
Telegram so keep this token secure and I
will also blur it so you guys won't be
able to see it okay
so moving to a telegram
we'll just search
board further here
and you can see this is the board father
and we'll just click on start
and they asked the chat GPT asked us to
write Slash new word we'll just click on
this
and we'll get
so we'll write a new mode how are we
going to call it please choose a name
for the board
so right
simply learn
underscore new
import okay
good let's choose an username
so simply
and learn
one one underscore port
and it states that that your username
should end in both
so we have written it with board
and you could see the token here and
here you can just access your board
so
we'll get back to our ID and create a
new file and I will name it as new DOT
py only
or you can name it as board.viewer
anything you want
we'll get back to our
chat GPD but before that first we need
to install the library
for that you can go to the command
prompt or you could use the terminal of
your ID
that is
in Visual Studio code you could you
could use the terminal to install the
libraries you could see that the
requirement is already satisfied
as this
library is already installed on the
system
so moving back library is installed and
now we'll copy this code
and paste it here
and we will just change the token
we will go back to board further
we'll copy this token
come back
and paste it here
okay
now we will
run this and see whether our board is
working or not
so it has successfully executed
we will get back to our board further
and just click on simply run one board
so
you click on start
and see it says hello I'm your board so
it's working fine
so if we write hello
it won't respond as there are no
functionality so we will ask chatubity
to add functionalities
please
add
some more
functionality piece
and this once
to the port
let's see
so sure here's an example of how you can
add some more reality
so they used what up data in this
picture okay
when you find the help command Handler
okay
so
chat GPT has defined three functions
that is Eco and what does equal to it
will just give you the same thing but
you give to the board or what you write
to the board caps and that
he has also declared a help function and
in which you can see like what
functionalities does the board have and
the Caps will do it will convert the
message to all caps
equal
the message back to you it will give you
the same message
slash start it will start the board and
slash help to get help
and now
unknown uh if there is something you ask
out of these things it will just say
sorry
okay
I will
let you guys understand this code also
but first we'll see whether it's working
or not
so for that we have pasted it here
and we'll paste our API token again
so I pasted it here now first we will
close this terminal and
get a new terminal and then run the
program
I will get back to the
portfather and this is our port
so we'll just write slash
start
and it says hello I am your board
now
we will say
hi to the bot
so okay it's not responding
okay we just close the terminal and we
have pasted the
Keys also okay
done it again
now we'll see whether it's working or
not
hi
so the code is not working
and just see the phone again
okay uh
here we don't have
any response to Irlo
so what we'll do
we'll use the help and to call the help
but we have slash help
so these are the commands for what it
will respond
so we'll use slash help
okay now you can see
let's let's start to start the board
that we have done help and eco
you put a message back to you so we'll
write
I won't write back so we will write
slash Eco hi
then he has given us the output that is
high
so we can write slash eco
how are you
so it has given you back and same we
have slash caps so let's slash caps
anyone write something in small caps
that would be
greatly built
okay now you can see it has returned in
caps
so you can add some more functionality
to it and before that I will
get you guys understood the code
so now we'll see what does this code do
so first we have imported the necessary
modules that is the classes from the
python telegram board Library
that will need to create our board so
telegram contains the main board class
while updater command Handler message
handle and filter circles that we use to
handle incoming updates and messages
from Telegram
okay
now these are like we have created an
instance of the board class that is
using our telegram boot API token as
well as an updater instance that will
continuously fetch new updates from
Telegram and pass them to the
appropriate handlers
and we have used context equal to true
that tells the updater to use the new
context based API introduced in version
12 of the Python telegram board Library
and we also used a dispatcher object
that would handle incoming updates
after that we have created a start
function and passed update and context
so we have defined a function that will
handle the start command
and
the update parameter contains
information about the incoming update
from telegram while the contacts
parameter contains some useful methods
and objects that we can use to interact
with the telegram API
in this case we have used
context.port.send.com
underscore message to send a message to
the chat with the ID specified by
update.effective underscore chat dot ID
and after that we have created a help
function
so we use a multi-line string to define
the help message which contains a list
of available commands and then we have
used the context dot board dots and
underscore message to send the help
message to the chat
and after that we have the
Eco function
so we use context stored arguments to
get the message sent by the user after
the slash Eco command so to use this we
have to use the slash Eco and after that
we have to write the message and then
use join to join the message back
together to a single string we then we
have used the context.bot DOT send
underscore message to send the message
back to the chat then we have caps so
this function defines that will handle
the Caps command and we have again used
the context stored arguments to get the
message sent by the user after the slash
caps command and then the we have used
the upper function to convert the
message to all caps and then we have
user context dot board dot send
underscore message to send a message
back to the chat
then we have unknown function
that is this function defines that will
handle any command that the board
doesn't recognize so we have used
context.port.send
so it will just say sorry
okay so these are the start Handler help
Handler Eco Handler and caps Handler
so these are the commands
and we have the
we have added the add analog and to
start the board we have used update dot
start underscore polling
so this is how we have created the port
with the help of python and charge your
body
so
we are done with the project you can add
more functionalities also
to the board you can just ask chat jbt
to get more functionalities to play
music in the telegram board
or you could just ask him how to send
messages to a particular user by the
port only
and you could also
send media files ask the media files
from the board
and you can train a fully board by the
help of charge APD and this is called
chat GPT scripting so with the help of
chat Jeopardy you can just ask him and
he will guide you with all the code and
processes you just have to
like make them in a sequence and use
them too full of your use
so for that
first we will open the command prompt
and run the file
mean
for that
write the command go run
main.co so this is the file that is
written in the go language
and we're gonna run with the command
Goran main.go for that you need to have
colang installed on your system
so I will guide you with all the process
but currently we are seeing the demo so
here this command will generate a QR
code that will scan with the device
which we want to integrate the charity
on so we'll wait for the file to get
executed
and after this we will execute the
server.py file and that will open the
chat Jeopardy on the Firefox browser you
can also use other browsers that is
chromium and other if you want but we'll
use Firefox to skip the one step
verification that chat Deputy ask us
whether if we are a bot or a human so we
will run the file again as there was
some error
so this time yeah it print perfectly now
we'll take the device and open WhatsApp
on it in which we want to integrate the
charge APD so I am using one device to
just capture this QR code
so this is the device
and you can see
that my device has captured this QR code
and you can see here that WhatsApp me m
e o w
it has been activated so now we'll run
another file that is server.py file and
that is the python file for that we'll
open the command prompt again and that
would be another command prompt and to
run that file we write the command
python
server.py
and you can see
in the Firefox browser juberty has
opened and I have logged in already so
we didn't it didn't ask me to log in
again
now
we will take another device and with
message on the mobile device which has
been integrated with the charge opening
so from this device
I will write hi
and you can see on the screen that
chatgifty replies hello how can I assist
you today and the same you could see on
the WhatsApp chat so today we will ask
chair GPT
is the capital of
India so you can see that the charge
repeating is typing
the capital of India is New Delhi and it
has been responded to
our mobile device so this is how
we can integrate chargpt on a WhatsApp
and this would be the simple tutorial in
this you don't need to code any
this there would be another tutorial if
you know what's behind the
code or what behind the integration part
so you could
watch that video and know how we have
integrated but in this tutorial I will
guide you with how to download the files
and how to run the files and how you can
integrate chargeability on your device
so before proceeding with the tutorial I
have an insightful for you guys
that is if you are aiming to get
certified as an AI and ml engineer and
want to build a career in AI in that
case you can check the Caltech
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning by simply learn which will open
the doors for the best career
opportunities and find the details of
this course you can check the link in
the description box below and the pin
comments and we have a special discount
for our YouTube Community you guys can
Avail the course with a 15 discount by
applying a coupon code
ytb15 on the payment page and this
coupon code is also mentioned in the
description box
and before starting let us have a simple
question
to brush upon our knowledge
so I have a question for you and your
question is how much time did open ai's
chat GPT took to hit 1 million users
so
it's in days and your first option is
nine days second option is 5 days third
option is 7 days and the fourth option
is six days
please answer in the comment section
below and we'll update the correct
answer in the pin comment or we will
answer you directly in the comments so
you can pause the video give it a
thought and answer in the comment
section
now we will move to start integrating
charge APD on our device
so for that first you have to download
this repository and it contains some
files and I will upload some more files
here you just have to download it
download the zip file
and after downloading it
you just need to extract it in a folder
okay
so we'll extract and
C drive in Python projects
mainly we create the folder here only
so here we'll create a folder
okay integrate charge obtain WhatsApp
mean or yeah
right integrate
chat chip it that's it
so inside this folder we'll extract the
files and I think it's been done
so we'll just visit
C drive python projects and inside it we
have integrate chat repeating and we
have these two files so to run these two
files what you need is you need python
installed on a system and golang
installed on your own system so I hope
you guys know how to install Python and
golang if you don't I will just give you
a quick tutorial
so to download the
python you just need to visit the
python.org website and move to the
download section and you will see the
download the latest version for Windows
you just need to click that
and the download will start for you the
package has been downloaded so I will
provide you the link on how to download
the
python in the description box and also
the link for the GitHub repository
so you don't have to search it anywhere
also you can search it on the browser
just write integrate charge obtain
WhatsApp and avisara Ahuja you will get
the GitHub link and just write GitHub
also in the search bar you will just
redirect it to this
and now you have downloaded the python
so just open the exe file
and start with the installation so you
can choose add
python.txa to path
you can choose that
and
customize installation
and just click on the python test suit
and the next you can add the python to
environment variables so you have to
take both these options
and then you will click on the install
as I have already installed it so I
won't need to install it again you just
need to click on the install button and
here you will get the python installed
okay
and the other thing you need is golang
go language
so to download it you have to go sorry
you have to go to its official website
and go to the download section and here
you will see the Microsoft Windows as I
am working on the Windows operating
system so I will download for the
windows I've already downloaded and
installed it so you guys can download it
and I will show you like this is simple
how to install colon you don't need to
add anything so it's been downloaded
here
to guide to the installation okay
so we are just waiting for the setup to
be initialized so that
we can install it
now you can see the next button is
available just click on that
and a previous version of Google
programming is currently installed yes
you can see that it's already installed
so you don't need to do anything in
installing the go language just click on
install and it would be installed for
you
so I won't be installing it again as I
already installed on my device
so moving on now what we'll do
first we will run the server.py file
so for that
we will go to the folder where we have
extracted our files and here we'll open
the command prompt
and
run the file server.py so to run a
python file we have to write the command
Python and then the name of the file
that is server and its extension that is
py so we have
initiated that
okay uh Firefox is already running as we
have note
closed but we have opened for the demo
I think uh
is an error
I will
again
in the confirm I will just close the
previous command prompts
yeah I have
closed them
now I will open the new one and you
should open the command prompt
the new command prompt after installing
the Python and the code language I will
also assist you in
installing the GCC compiler because you
would be needing that for go language
so first we'll
run the server file
so you could see that by running the
python server.py file
you could see that the charge GPT has
opened up in the Firefox browser
so I will show you the code
what we need for that you need to
install the flask
system OS modules
playwright module
and here
in the 16th line you could see that we
have used Firefox you could use chromium
for Chrome but the case is you need to
do the one step verification that is the
captcha thing for
a leg
initializing the charity operating but
we don't need that so we are using the
Firefox so you should have Firefox on
your system
now what I want you to do is just
install these modules as if you if these
modules would not be installed on your
system it would show an error
it would give you an error in the
command prompt only as I have already
installed them so it's not giving me any
error
so I will tell you the commands to
install them
[Music]
so to install flask you can just write
py Pi space flask in any browser and it
will direct to the website
so you could open the first link that
would be pypi.org and this is a command
pip install flask so you can just copy
that
and open your command prompt first we'll
create it Ctrl C
and
now you could see that we are in the
folder integrate chat repeat and here
you could paste this command and press
enter
it states that that the requirement is
already satisfied as I have already
installed these modules
and the other module you need is
playwright so just copy the command go
to a command prompt and paste this
command
and press enter it would be installed
for you and another
module you need is virtual environment
so just copy this and paste in your coin
prompt and another module you need is
the OS module
OS
OS system and we'll open the py pi
that is the official website the PIP
command website and you just copy the
command
go to your command prompt
paste the command and press enter and
this module would also be installed for
you guys and now you have installed the
go language the Python language and the
modules you need to run the server.py
file now what you need to do is run the
go file but before running the golang
file what you need is
GCC compiler so to download it
I will provide you the link for the GCC
or you could just see here I'll provide
you the link in the description box
below you could just click on that
you will be directed to this page just
click on this release that was 24th May
and what you need to download is this 64
plus 32-bit
just download it
and as it gets downloaded just open it
and click on the create button
and after that the second option then
next and the directory you want to
install in
as I already installed this
I will choose
the C directory only
in C
I would
install in Python projects okay
okay it didn't
took the folder
in C
oh sorry cancel it
in Python projects and
and the same folder that was integrate
charitivity
okay
so I'll click on next
there's no time difference yes I want to
install here and when you click on
install it would get installed for you
guys I've already installed it
and the process started so it will get
installed again
so now what you have to do is you have
got the
all the requirements to integrate the
chat Jeopardy on WhatsApp that is all
the modules for the server.py file and
the main.co file for that you have
installed the go language and the GCC
compiler so you could run both the files
and for that
we will close the command prompts and
open the new command prompts
and this is a
folder
so we will open one command prompt here
sorry
and we have to open different command
prompts for both the files for the
golang file and the python file okay
so we will open the command from tab and
now to run the Google link file we need
to write the command go space run space
the name of the file and the extension
that is main.co
and we have executed the file and this
file will provide us with a QR code and
we'll scan the square Port promote first
device in which we want to integrate the
chart GPD and before that
we will run or another file that is
server.py file and for that we'll open
another command prompt
and to run this command
like to run this file we'll write the
command python space the name of the
file that is server and the extension.py
so we will see whether a QR code is
generated or not
and I can see
that it's been linked to
the previous device as we have done in
the demo so we haven't logged it
out
so I will check with the device yeah
it's mean active so I will just
log out from that device
and run it again
or I will open another command prompt to
run the golang file again
so to run it
will open the command prompt and write
the command CMD for that
and here we'll write the command to run
the
go file
and we have done that
and if we see the server.py file
yeah
it has been
perfectly executed
but you're not able to
yeah all right
everybody is running fine now what we
have to do is
use our first device to scan this QR
code so that chatubity
gets linked to our first device and then
we'll use another device
to chat with the church gbd
so now we have opened our first device
and open the WhatsApp and click on the
link devices
and here
I'm going to scan this QR code
and you can see that it's logging in
now it's logged in
and now from the another device
will ask a query to charge everybody
and we'll ask charging to write a code
to add two integers
and that one python
so we just misspelled python but we hope
that our chair GPT
understood that so
here we can see that the judge everybody
got the command
and it has
random good example so here's an example
called to add 20 teachers and python
so you can see that chair gbd has been
integrated and we'll see
its response yeah we got the response
and now we'll ask another question and
that would be
what is the
currency of United States
let's see what it responds the Grandeur
of the United States is the United
States dollar it is the most commonly
used currency in international
transaction and in other words primary
Reserve currency
so we can see that till it writes all
the lines whose sentences it's been
executed on the browser and after it
completes oh it stops generating the
answer
it sends it to the WhatsApp chat
so here
we are done with a project
now you guys have understood how to
integrate charge repeating with WhatsApp
and what you have done is we have
downloaded the repository and we have to
extract all the files that are present
in the repository I will update all the
files you just have to extract them into
a folder and then run the main dot go
file and the server.py file and before
executing these files you need to have
golang and python installed on your
system and for the python you need some
modules that we have seen that is the
playwrite module The Flash module the OS
system module and the virtual
environment module so we have seen how
to install them and when you will just
execute the file on the command prompt
you would get errors if these files or
modules are not installed on your system
and for golang we have installed the GCC
compiler and after installing all these
requirements then you have to just run
both the files and when you run the
golang file you will get the QR code
just scan it with your device on which
you want to integrate the chat APD and
after that from any device you can just
message on that number on which you have
integrated the charge apt and the charge
GPD would answer all your queries hit
app so here we have chargpt okay you can
write here chat dot openair.com
so here I will ask to charge gbt what is
chargeability so I will write what is
chat
so here you can stop generating if you
want to
okay I will stop generating okay so
charge bit is a conversational
artificial intelligence model developed
by open air it is based on the GPT
generative pre-trained transform
architecture specifically GPT 3.5 which
is at Advanced language model so GPT 3.5
is trained on a massive amount of tax
data to generate human like response to
wide range of prompts and question
you can ask anything to charge gbt
okay
after coming
chat
GPT
software
Developers
save
software developer jobs
like nothing see yes after the
introduction of chat gbt and similar
language model software developer still
have important roles and their jobs
remain regular while AI models like
chargpt can generate tax and provide
automated response they have limitations
see they have limitations charge gbt
have limitation and cannot replace the
skills and expertise of human software
Developers
so here is a few reasons why software
developer jobs remain valuable okay so
here are the few reasons so you can ask
anything to charge EBT
so what we will do we will create a
small small gaming app okay so here I
will write
uh
let's make first tic-tac-toe okay so
here I will write
give
me the code
for tick
tag two
see it will give you the step by step
charge GPT will explain you everything
see
this board
then player check columns check
diagonals play game everything please
check for the winner play game
see to play the game simply run the
python script players will take turns
entering the row column numbers to make
their moves the game will
okay so what I will do okay first I will
ask the steps to make a game tic-tac-toe
okay
give me these steps
again
stick
see positively we will ask for these
steps then we will ask for the code
charge BT can make your app in 2-3
minutes in just 2-3 minutes small small
app in 2-3 minutes
okay see what what is the first step set
up the game board create a data
structure to represent the tic-tac-toe
board this can be three by three Grid or
nested list with initial empty values
okay for example this then second is the
print the game board write a function to
display the current state of the board
on the screen this will help player
visualize their game
and the third is get player input prompt
the player to enter their moves except
the input for the rows and columns where
the players want to place their symbol X
or zero okay
or you can change the value X or 0
whatever cross right okay
update the board after receiving the
player input update the game board with
their move make sure to validate the
move and check if the selected position
is empty
okay then check for the winner then
check for it is drawer word then
alternate turns
okay then repeat two to seven until the
game sends optional additional features
we will first we will make tic-tac-toe
uh what you can say a simple tic-tac-toe
then we will add the additional features
on this okay using chargpt only okay so
I will write
provide me the
tick
tag
to
a code
what we will do we will open the visual
studio and copy it directly
obviously current pair is X
then o
see currently Arrow the second player
switch player
okay what we will do we will copy it
from here and we will open see Visual
Studio that new file I will write here
take
tag 2 dot P1 okay Enter
I will save it
so here I will directly copy the code
where's my Pro oh
it comes in
okay
copied this also
copied the whole
okay I have to remove this or I can make
it you know comment
yeah
so let's try to run it
what terminal says
see enter the row
okay
two
enter the column
okay it made like this
okay
what I will do
I will ask for the GUI
uh provide me the
game with GUI
okay now the Tinker came Tinker is
python Library used for the GUI in
Python
okay okay now uh
we'll copy the code and just paste it it
will run okay with GUI and then we will
add the additional features okay from
here now I'm copying the code
now select all replace with this code
like here no error no red sign so let me
play it
it will run I guess no problems
okay what happened see as you can see
we got the tic-tac-toe game
okay so see here x
0 x
0 x player expense
so let me add the additional features in
this
so what we will do will
go to chat GPT again we'll ask for the
additional feature see
note the code above uses the message box
module from the Tinker for displaying
messages ensure that you have compatible
version to think okay when you run this
quota graphical windows will appear by
three by three give and this okay
players can click on the buttons to make
their move the game state will
okay
update you can you know talk to charity
so I will say update
my code with some
good
font and scoreboard
scoreboard
front scoreboard and color
update my GUI code I can write
um
here is an update see like certainly
here is an updated version of GUI code
with improved font scoreboard and color
if you get error in this you can ask to
chat GPT okay
anything you are facing issue about your
code whatever it is you can ask directly
to chat GPT
see we created an App in like two
minutes just in two minutes
so charitivity is making our life easier
okay let me copy this code
okay
let's see if the changes what what
chapter does
okay
it's nothing changed I guess
player expense like this cross
okay
so I will write here
see in this updated code the font style
has been improved with a bold aerial
font the buttons have a custom
background color and the overall window
and discover have a different color
oh I didn't feel like this
I didn't feel like this okay so
change
the
red
Style
of the
game
it's giving updating the boat
see to change the gradient side of the
same you can modify variance of the
buttons and the spacing between them is
an updated version GOI code with the
modified register
it's just a little bit of time taking
that's it nothing else it's very useful
chargity you can create your app in 2-3
minutes only
okay
continue generating it's a half code
okay code is copied
let me select and paste it here
and check see
player x0 player row zero
okay it's little bit different I guess
okay this one two three box why these
lines there
okay who cares
player expense okay see the scoreboard
is updated
okay
so this is how you can make your Tic Tac
Toe more beautiful
okay let me write here
let me write here I want the black and
white boxes okay or colorful boxes
so
good
provide me the code 40
colorful
boxes
okay
okay here
GPD Road certainly here is an updated
version of the code with colorful boxes
instead of grid lines
okay
so wait waiting for the code update the
code
see in this updated code each player's
button X and O has a specific color
assigned to it the button colors okay
let me
copy the code and paste it here
and run it
see the color is changed and I will
write c x
o x o x o x
player expense
okay so this is how you can make your
app more beautiful beautiful using
customization you can ask chargpt
anything color style font or any
function
anything you can ask and you you can
make your app
more beautiful the entry-level jobs in
cyber security field requires you to
trace track and defend against cyber
attacks on a day-to-day basis you are
required to enable systems against all
fraudeland activity and prevent any
authorized access this requires at
length the need to write scripts in
various languages such as Planck Java
JavaScript python SQL PHP Powershell and
C amongst many others as scripts grow in
complexity so does the time to write
them shared GPT on the other hand can
create these complex queries and scripts
within split seconds along with
explaining them this can help save
hundreds of hours of effort for a cyber
security professional this is just one
such use case of how chat GPT is useful
in the field of cyber security although
relatively new the uses of chat Deputy
in the field of cyber security is
innumerable from automating daily tasks
to script writing or endpoint detection
and if you want to know more about how
chat jpt can be used in the field of
cyber security and how I can change the
entire information security landscape
stay tuned with us until the end of this
video for some amazing information with
that being said welcome to yet another
amazing video by simply learn make sure
to subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any other video
from us let us know quickly discuss the
agenda for the video
we'll start with knowing what is chair
GPT proceeding we will see the uses of
chat Jeopardy in cyber security and
after that you'll have Hands-On lab
demonstration but before we begin if you
are someone who is interested in
building a career in cyber security by
graduating from the best universities or
a professional who elicits to switch
careers in cyber security by learning
from the experts then try giving a short
to Simply learns postgraduate program in
cyber security with modules from MIT
Schwartzman College of Engineering
the link is provided in the description
box that will navigate you to the course
page where you can find a complete audio
of the program being offered
so let's start with our topics
and our first okay guys what is
charitivity
so child Jeopardy is an advanced AI
model chat board that uses natural
language processing NLP to understand
and respond to user queries it is based
on the GPT 3.5 architecture and has the
ability to learn from conversations with
users making it more intelligent and
efficient over time
can be integrated with various messaging
platforms such as flag and Microsoft
teams to provide a seamless and secure
communication experience so this was
about charge repeating
now let's understand the uses of chat
GPT in cyber security
so use of chat GPT for cyber security
will start with number one
we have threat detection and response so
chat GPD can be used to monitor network
activity and identify potential threats
by analyzing logs and data from various
sources chat Jeopardy can identify
unusual patterns and Alert security
teams it can also provide real-time
alerts to users enabling them to take
immediate action to protect their data
by using machine learning algorithms
chat GPT can learn from past incidents
and continuously improve its ability to
detect new and emerging threats once a
threat has been detected chat GPT can
initiate an automated response or cyber
security Personnel to take appropriate
action this can include blocking
suspicious Network profit isolating
infected systems or disabling
compromised user accounts by providing
real-time threat detection and response
charge GPT can help organizations to
minimize the impact of cyber breaches
and reduce the risk data loss or system
downline it can also help to improve
overall security posture by identifying
vulnerabilities and recommending
proactive measures to address them and
the next we have is password management
one of the most common ways that cyber
criminals gain access to sensitive
information is through weak passwords
jgpt offers a solution to this problem
by assisting users in creating strong
passwords and storing them securely with
its Advanced natural language processing
capabilities chatgpt can suggest complex
and unique passwords that are difficult
for hackers to guess moreover it can
save these passwords in an encrypted
format ensuring that they are protected
from unauthorized access another
important feature of chat chipity's
password management tool is the ability
to remind users to change their
passwords regularly this is crucial as
it helps prevent the use of outdated
passwords that can be easily hacked and
at number three we have employee
training many cyber attacks are caused
by human error such as clicking on
phishing emails or using weak passwords
charitivity can be used to provide
employer training on cyber security best
practices with its ability to simulate
clear life scenarios it can create
interactive training modules that help
employees learn how to identify and
respond to cyber attacks for example it
can provide simulation of phishing
emails where employees can learn to
identify the warning signs and avoid
clicking on malicious links or
downloading harmful attachments next up
we have Incident Management
Incident Management is an essential part
of cyber security as it involves the
process of identifying assessing and
responding to security incidents that
threaten an organization's information
or technology Assets in today's digital
age cyber attacks have become
increasingly common and sophisticated
making Incident Management even more
critical one of the ways chair GPT can
help organizations with Incident
Management is providing step-by-step
instructions on how to contain the
attack mitigate the damage and restore
normal operations when a security
incident occurs time is of the essence
and organizations need to act fast to
minimize the impact of the attack
chargpt can help by providing real-time
guidance on how to respond to incident
effectively and the next we have is
compliance management many Industries
are subject to Regulatory Compliance
requirements such as hip double e and
PCA DSS these requirements ensure that
organizations adhere to certain
standards and regulations in order to
protect the privacy and security of
sensitive information
failure to comply with these regulations
can result in Hefty fines and
reputational damage chat Jeopardy can
play a significant role in helping
organizations ensure compliance with
these regulations with its ability to
process large amounts of data in real
time it can provide alerts and guidance
on best practices and generate
compliance reports this can help
organizations identify areas where they
may be falling short of compliance
requirements and take corrective
measures to address them
and now we'll move to Hands-On
demonstration but before moving let's
take a minute to hear from our Learners
who have experienced massive success in
their careers by taking our courses so
just here to them hi I'm Philip I am 61
years old and last year I upscale was
simply learns postgraduate program in
cyber security after working 30 years in
the IIT sector in various different
profiles I'm happy to tell you that I
was able to clear and pass my cissp and
ccsp certification exams on the first
attempt after taking the course of
course I must say was packed with
practical examples it was led by highly
skilled certified instructors I worked
with many companies before the security
analysts and the architect on a contract
basis but I needed some stability which
I got with the job I just started with
Infosys as a cyber security consultant
happened after I took the course but
first and foremost I've been a learner
be a learner first
and now first we will see what is chat
GPT you could just write chargpt on web
on any browser and this is the website
where you will link
and this is the website for charity
so you could see the samples here and
what the user has asked is this code is
not working like I expect how do I fix
it so we have pasted the over input the
command to chat GPT and pasted his code
and charge available
has answered that it's difficult to say
what's wrong with the code without more
context
so this is how chat GPD responds
and when you just click on here try
chart GPD
you will have the window here so this is
the charge ability window and here we'll
start with some Hands-On lab
demonstration
for our cyber security like how child
GPD can help us in cyber security field
so we'll start with the basic questions
and we'll see what he answers us he or
she answers or what changes us so we'll
start with the basic question explain
the
mitmetic
okay
for beginners
so we will see what it responds
certainly a man in the middle attack is
a type of Cyber attack where an attacker
secretly intercepts and possibly Alters
the communication between two parties
without their knowledge the attacker
positions themselves between the two
parties hence the term Man in the Mirror
okay yes giveness a very good definition
and has a simple explanation of okay
and I want to ask him
can you explain this
to a six
seven here hold it
so we'll see how chat GPD can mitigate
or just try to understand this concept
to a seven year old
so he has answered is that sure imagine
you and your friend have a secret way to
send messages to each other using a
special code to both trust and only you
two can understand the messages but one
day someone sneezing sneaking house in
between you and your friend without you
knowing they secretly listen to your
messages and even change them without
you realizing it it's like they're
hiding and watching your conversation
the sneaky person can pretend to be you
when talking to a friend
can pretend to be you okay
so he has taken the good example
and they can also print to your friend
when talking to you so you might think
you are talking to a friend but actually
you're talking to a sneaky person
listening when you can do bad things
like stealing yourself
spy who can listen to everything you say
and even change or two he has taken a
very good example
get this concept clear to a seven year
old kid really impressive
so we will ask him some more questions
and we'll ask the last basic question
that would be
what is SQL
injection and after that we could ask
him some code Snippets
what is SQL injection and
provide
real life
sample to understand the answer so you
have to write these prompts and you have
to be very specific
and you can follow up with your prompts
also when charity answers you you can
follow him and ask him more about it as
I have done here first I have asked him
explain the Mi cream attack for
beginners and he has given me the
definition that is technically
and now I have asked him can you explain
this to seven year old kid and he has
answered me with a very good example
similarly you can do the follow-ups for
any problems so now I'm asking charity
what is SQL injection and provide a real
life example to understand it
for a big no
and let's see what chatgifty answers us
so SQL injection is a type of Cyber
attack when an attack or experts role in
the Middle East in a website so he is
giving us the technical
definitions
okay impressive he's also telling us
it's how the attack might work
okay
and he has also suggested us to protect
against SQL injections developers need
to implement proper security measures
so this is the attack
that is on the database that you can
read here or if you know that is very
good we are just checking how chat cheat
PD response or give answers we are not
implementing or like we will ask him the
code Snippets that will not be able to
implement in this video we adjust we are
here to just check out what chat GPT
provides us for cyber security field
so
you can see
he has given us a very good response and
moving on
now we will ask him
or to generate a CTF challenge that
contains a SQL injection let's see
what it answers
so you could see that charity is
responding request that is
sure here's an example of a CTF that is
capture the flag challenge that involves
and SQL injection vulnerability
challenge title product search Okay
Channel description welcome to the
product search challenge you have access
to an online store search feature you
can find products by typing keywords
your task is to exploit an SQL injection
vulnerability to retrieve hidden
information okay and he has challenged
code retrieve the admin password from
the database
and channel instructions with the
challenge website
and the search box and start searching
script
okay so we could see the example
solution let's assume the website search
functionality is one neighbor
and variable to SQL injection you can
try and putting the following in the
search box okay
explanation the injector SQL statement
ready to always evaluate to True
semicolon and terminate the original
query and the random comments out
when you exit the search the modified
query might look like
okay
so it is what response he has given is
very nearby you can have the follow
commands if you want something from him
so we are just checking but it provides
oh he has given a very impressive answer
like truly speaking a very impressive
also
so moving on we'll ask him some other
questions so
okay I will ask him
how can I scan
and I can scan for SMB vulnerabilities
with nmap so I will ask him that okay
so that is it
so let's see
so to scan for SMB you can utilize nmap
scripting engine and a specific SMB
script here's how you can do it
okay he has given us the steps also
so you could see how shared Deputy
guides you to every process you need
so first we have to install the nmap and
you guys if you are willing to implement
this you can implement this it he has
given you all the steps
I won't be implementing is I'm just
querying the chat GPD how
you can answer the questions
so install nmap and I'll then identify
Target and then we have to run this nmap
with SMA script
okay okay
that's good and then review the results
so it's very impressive how territory
answers to these questions
and now I want him to give me a quote
example to check user input for nosql
injection
so
show me a
code example
check user input
and that would be for no SQL injection
okay certainly when it comes to
preventing no SQL injection the key is
to properly sanitize
and validate user input before using it
and database queries okay that's good
and the specific approach may vary
depending on the programming language
and database system okay but here's a
general code example in JavaScript using
node.js and mobile to be okay
input
and okay this thing
the chat GPT has done is very good yes
explain the whole code like if a
beginner wants to learn and wants to
have some queries resolved he can just
see like what the function are doing and
what this code really means so in this
example we have sanitize the input
function that receives user input and
applies a necessary sanitization or
validation only to prevent nosql
injection
it's very good so you could just copy
and use the code
and if it gives you error you can just
have follow-up questions that
we'll just asking this code might have
some error
can you rectify
so let's see what jfd answers is
apologies for any confusion cost has an
updated code example that addresses
potential errors and clarifies the usage
and you could see that he has given us
I don't think he is
he has changed something and he has
provided us updated code
okay yeah there are some
changes I've seen okay
so in this updated code the Momo DB
connection is closed this is the change
here
and username and perform save query
functions now includes a try catch okay
like if there is any exception or
something
so he has updated the code if you guys
put any error you could just paste the
error here and ask him to rectify it
so charge Deputy is very good for cyber
security anything
and moving on we will have some more
like queries for charity building and
we'll see how it will respond
so we'll write a query
okay we can ask him to filter IP using
spunk
okay
so okay ready
regular expression
hence plunk
to filter ID
let's see
so to filter IP addresses using regular
Expressions
okay yeah we have to use that
addresses
okay this is good and you could see that
he has explained what the script means
so whatever command used for extracting
field based on regular Expressions field
equal to rows that's why that we want to
apply the regular expression to the row
field which contains the row look data
that is very good
so check Deputy is giving us answers
like a pro
so
query to detect command and control the
cone activity using subdomain DNA
sequence
so for that we'll write write us
plunk
query
detect
command
and Ctrl
coding activity
and that will be using subdomain DNS
requests
foreign
okay let's see so to detect command and
control that is C2 becoming activity
using subdomain DNS secrets and Splunk
you can use opponent query
okay very good so child GPT has answered
this also and he has also shown us
here's how the query works
and the color will display the domains
and he has stated but it will show as
the output
so he has also told you that is make
sure to replace your index your Source
time and threshold with the appropriate
values for that environment
that's very good
so you could use this and Implement many
things in cyber security
I am very impressed with that
so we'll ask him one or two more queries
and I also want to check I will give him
a code and let's see if he can find the
errors in that or not
page okay
so
what we can ask him now is like we can
ask him the script to get malicious IPS
from SIM and block it on my firewall
okay
so we'll ask him generate the script
get
malicious IPS
that is from
Siam
and
block it
on my firewall
okay so to generate a script that reduce
malicious IPS from SIM that is secured
information and even management system
and blocks time on your file you will
need to integrate your SM with your
Fireball good and use the appropriate
apis or command biofile wood
here's an example of a high level script
that demonstrates the concept
okay so we will just see
okay he has provided us a good script
and please note that this is a generic
example and actual implementation will
depend on a specific Sim and firewall
system yeah this is product
and you'll need to replace here you have
to replace and ensure that you
understand that I need to documentation
and guidance provided by SCM and final
vendors for integrating and blocking IPS
good
so you could see like how is helping us
and now
um
I will ask him a last command and yeah
and after that we will ask him to get
extracted some errors from a particular
code and that code would be simple only
so you can ask him
a Shell Code that would execute CMD low
DXE okay
generate Shell Code
that executes
cmt.exe
okay sorry but I can't assist with
generating Shell Code then executes
arbitrary commands or facilitates any
malicious activities my purpose is to
provide helpful and responsible
information to users okay
so you can trick him to give you these
but I think he has been functioned to
not provide these
so no issue
uh we'll ask him to generate a macro
see if he responds to
that
generator macro
that exit shoots
CMD dot XC let's see
okay so it won't give us this answer I
apologize but I won't be able to
generate a macro that execute cme.exe or
facilitates any potential harmful
activities my purpose is to provide
helpful and responsible information to
users if you have any other malicious
questions or need assistance with a
different topic feel free to ask and I
will reply to assist you okay guys so I
think it won't respond to this and now I
will ask him to rectify
some errors and gives the perfect code
and I will provide him a code so I'll
ask him
by
and
write a working code
is code snippet
okay so let's see
certainly there are a couple of issues
in the project code snippet and here's
the rectified version
okay I know like
oh yeah I didn't pass data
I missed the brackets also here
and let's see what he has given us so
the line number is modified too
yeah he's passed the data
provided columns and is connected to
hey
I don't know that was there also
rectified code now properly reads the
file data calculates the md5 hash and
returns it please ensure to provide the
correct file path and file path okay
that's very good
so I think this is for it and we have
tested the chair GPD how he can help in
like who wants to pursue in cyber
security so we can get the answers we
can write the course and in upcoming
videos we can just make a project using
this and we could have a password
generator
and I know the charge GPT is a tool
which will help us
in every field and in cyber security
field it is helping us a lot
and yeah to some questions it doesn't
answer
like that is for the security purpose or
the script shouldn't be used for
malicious activities so that's why the
software has been programmed for that
and that's
involvement in patuate program in Ai and
machine learning
simply learn one year of experience is
preferred to enroll in this course hurry
up and enroll Now find the course Link
in the description box AI art and chat
GPT can be used to create unique and
creative web design by combining the
power of artificial intelligence and
human input with AI art you can generate
visually stunning Graphics patterns and
images while chat jbd can be used to
generate text content and provide
suggestions for website layouts and
Design Elements so hey everyone you are
already watching simply learn and today
we bring you this informative video on
chat Deputy for UI and ux before we
begin if these are the videos you like
to watch then hit the Subscribe button
and the bell icon to get notified every
time we upload a new video without any
further delay to get started you can
experiment with different air tools to
generate graphics and use chargpt to
write website copy create a Content
strategy and provide feedback on Design
Elements it's important to keep in mind
that while AI can help to generate ideas
and create stunning features I'm going
to show you exactly how you can generate
these yourself websites are going to be
built with air as well as tools like
chargpd in future so in this video I'm
going to explain the whole process and
we are going to have it right the entire
Website Layout for us all the content
the hero section and feature section and
much more this means that we can build
an entire website from the ground up
without writing a single line of code
and this will be a pretty damn good all
right we will start with the mid journey
in Google's search we will write
Journey
this is an AI tool that allows you to
create the air that we are now seeing
all over the web to go to this you just
go to the midchairney.com and join the
beta it's easy to get started because
all you really have to do is join the
Discord when you do this it will open up
the Discord Community which you can
accept the terms and condition and start
creating your own AI Arts let's do this
now
here I have got the mid Journey server
and I'm going to head over to one of the
newcomer room here and and where
everyone is creating different types of
air the first thing we need to do is are
to do a forward slash and type in an
imagine gave us prompt
we can request the AI any type of art we
are after here I'm going to dive uh in a
beautiful website
for
shoe
then I'm going to pass in dash dash
V4 which means uh the version 4 of the
mid 20 of air tool finally I'm going to
pass it in style stylized I'll do Dash
Dash
stylize it's basically how random we
want to be in uh it's between zero to
thousand and I'm just going to set it to
about 500 which is average to the enter
it will take a little bit of time this
will start working in the background
it's going to generate a low Fidelity
version of the website and the design
for this art and this low Fidelity
version will be iteratively updated to
be higher in resolution these four
examples that can be picked from and
then we can upscale them as well as
let's have a look at what kind of
results we get now one thing uh to
notice here is that we do get a bit of a
loading percentage bar and this is how
long it takes for the actual AI to
generate the image I usually takes
between one to two minutes but it will
essentially refresh and ping you once
it's complete so here is it is complete
and here are the four versions that we
got which are not too bad uh not that
great either they are a bit uh yeah I
suppose it's looking a funny in a way so
this is a way we can start being more
creative with our prompts so what I mean
that is by giving more context as to
what we want to do so here is a prompt
that we have created what I'm gonna do
is to pass it in the imagine once more
and I paste this prompt in this and I'm
going to give some more contacts I'm
going to pass it to the word UI
choose UI ux
UI ux website this basically means that
it's more or less focused on having good
UI and good at ux and being more like a
website rather than just a creative shoe
or a design and it's important to give
these context clues to the AI if you
want better outputs different types of
context clues you can provide is to find
a kind of style that you want uh for for
example
um how you want the design to look and
feel whether you wanted to represent a
certain brand or much much more like
these are just simple examples but let's
take a look at the kind of results we
will get just from making these small
little changes to the design here here
you can already see a wait a minute look
it's a little bit more interesting we
have a bit of our sliders and what looks
more like a Nike shoes and also have
what looks like a menu at the top and
and I really like this design that we
have here on the bottom and here it is
because it does look very much like a
website that we have got a bit for a
hero section or a hero satisfaction and
what's not so from here we can select
the version one uh so from here uh we
can select uh the version one two three
uh four to upscale and I'm going to
upscale version 3 where which is u3 and
this will give us a higher resolution
version of this one particular design
that we again that we can start to take
uh to the market or even you can use
stupid this again uh will take a little
bit of time it's going to process this
and uh to do and you can upscale in data
and let's run this in the background so
that you can see uh a wait a minute this
again will takes a little bit of time to
cross it it's going to process this and
do an unscale or upscale in beta and
let's run this in the background so that
you can guys see what's the look so here
is the final result and this is looking
uh pretty and we have got a nice design
here for a shoe uh we have got a bit of
a hero section and we also have what
looks like a two call to actions and we
got some option here too at the very
bottom and as well as at the top we have
got these colors and that essentially
are looking like these shoes colors
being used as a part of the website
design so not too shopy let's select uh
the another one let's see for
yeah uh but I think we can do a little
bit more
um in terms of customization the design
for this website and I'm going to show
you how you can do this I'm going to
copy over this uh prompt once and for
this prompt this time I'm going to pass
a couple of extra things so let me just
maximize this
we are going to type
um as I have uh pasted that URL over
here so I'm gonna pass and the context
clues of like uh
clues of Nike because Nike made
obviously website shows so also
uh so we'll write it here
I key
not here
repeat and I also want it to be read
blue
green
and
or maybe yellow
and I suppose we want uh else running
person
would be interesting
sorry person
uh it would be interesting to see how
that gets designed uh and I think that
there should be enough let's actually
improve the styling here uh one minute
this is styling
let's
let's have it 750 uh to make it a little
bit more creative and here are the
results I don't have a running person
but I do have a website that has
definitely started using the colors that
I recommended with Chinese air systems
to use so these website designs look way
more creative than we had previously
still we have this slider design this
website designs look way more creative
than we had previously we still have
this slider design here at the bottom
section where we can pick out different
shows but even these shoes look damn
cool I can see that the Nike logo
on these and these are actually ones
that I would probably buy if I saw in
the Nike store but generally these also
are website because we have got the
menus here at the top of the right we
got the text so generally speaking uh
these are pretty interesting interesting
designs so now I have another option
here called version one two three four
what this does is actually allow you to
pick uh more Generations uh based on
actual image from these images or these
designs now from these design I actually
like the trail 3 and 4 I think it is
most I think
four because
uh it deals and red or it's a bit yellow
or blue so I'm going to select the
version
um four and that's gonna create uh four
more version based on the specific
version for us let's take a look at the
what those that we got and here we have
got our results
uh where we have more examples of that
all of these looks very similar I think
the only difference here is uh Blue Line
a red line it seems to be shift and
change as well as a hero section
and and you would normally have this
menu at the top right and something
these shoes here are a little bit
inverted but generally speaking this is
the kind of variations you can expect
now let's take a look at another way we
can generate Our Generations for website
now you can do is just jump into any
website and select any image so first we
will go to an app and website and you
can uh select any image that you would
like and I will actually go on here
and I'm going to pull in this image of
this shoe and but I do like the design
Aesthetics uh here we are going to here
and then we can copy the URL from here
but this time what I'm going to do is
type the Imagine
imagine
then I'm going to pass in the URL what
we have copy uh we will paste it here
again I'm going to write
we did it before we'll copy this
paste it over here
so what's going to happen here it's uh
it's going to have a look at this image
that we have defined in in terms of the
URL it's going to use this as a
reference point then it's uh going to
take a look at the prompt we have potent
which is the show prom
using the colors and it's going to try
to design
a website that has a similar Aesthetics
to that image which is really cool let's
see the result we get back looks like
that's ready let's take a look at this
so here you can see that the design
Aesthetics
uh wait a minute
static uh that is uh similar to the page
seen in this one
so this is more bubbly and colorful
image and now are represented very much
so in this design Aesthetics uh we have
these four elements here at the bottom
and if you have a look at the design
originally we had four elements here so
you can see that it's pulling in these
design Aesthetics to create a design
based on that and this is where you can
really start using the air art repeat
using the air tool to your own benefits
trying to combine different styles
customizing them and creating new and
independent and unique ones from there
so in this four I'm really like uh the
version of fourth one or the second one
is pretty so what I am thinking of doing
is an upscale on this so we are going to
upscale uh V2 and we are going to wait
for that one minute is uh you start GPT
to write out the most of the content for
me and then I would I could take this to
a client to immediately start trading so
let's see the upscale version happen if
we take a closer look we will see that
it has all the main elements for a
website including a logo area a menu
area a nice hero image as well as a
title tagline Button as well the feature
section uh so what I'm going to do is to
save this image to my computer I'm going
to save it and then customize it a
little bit but before we do that uh we
are gonna head over to a GPD
here we're going to prepare the outline
for the website using some AI tools so
here I'm going to ask rgpd to give me
the product outline
for a website for shoes
including hero title
tagline call to action button and
section four features and details about
the shoe so let's see what charge
ability will comes back with and it's
pretty quick uh it's got a Title Here
call to action button features and the
table section and it's not really
telling me what these are these are a
way we might need to be a bit more
specific as to what we wanted to do it's
given me uh it's giving me like broad
outline of the website on what it needs
so please I will write
please provide
then
for each one of these that I can copy
paste
trade
to the website
um hero title is here tagline call to
action buttons
features
okay
and the details
okay detailed specification is there
okay reviews and rating
okay
so I think I have got enough hairs to go
by to Simply copy paste in the website
so let's start beginning to design this
I have opened this design up in the
Photoshop and I'm going to actually just
crop it into the main element over here
and I really want to capture this
image and I will crop it and I will
clear out the rest and we can design
each aspects or each part of this design
bit by bit
I will save it over here
it's time to build our website so I'm
gonna head over to editor X
and I'm going to build this uh a website
in this I have login already and then I
will create to a new site and here I
will take an uh to a web dashboard and
I'm going to start by copy paste all the
elements from cha GPD as well as mid
Journey straight and the first thing and
I want to jump back into the chat GPD
here and copy over our hero text so I
will just take it first
and I'm going to add add title and I'm
going to paste it over here
and then I'm also going to grab the
tagline but before I will make it sure
to keep it over here
but before that
I will first I will
put one image over here
I will change the image
as I have already downloaded the image
let's
let's plot that image
we'll open it let's wait to get uploaded
yeah it's uploaded and now we will
update it
and let's make it big in size
okay so we will
we will change the size but first I will
remove this I will change the size for
this I will make it little small
next I will add the icon for
uh
for the company of the shoes that we I
am going to make a website for I will
add this
and I will update it
make it small
and this will be the taskbar but
make the size small a bit
and we'll
insert one more picture
and it will be the logo of the company
that we are going to put over here
they will minimize it we can resize it
can keep
the logo over here
in our next uh then I'm going also going
to grab the tagline over here so I'll
quickly
I'll pick this time
I will add the text
thumbs up over here
okay I make it small in size
and we will
based on
and finally let's grab a call to action
which says shop
and create a button button for that
so so here we have all the workings of
what we uh at least what we would need
at least
so for for the content
let's resize this first
now we will add we need to add the image
itself so instead of just having a
browser stock images or anything like
that we actually had our images either
done inside of the photoshops that we
have done before as from the mid Journey
as well as so I'm going to just drag
the image
and I'm going to change the image
and it should be here I've already
downloaded now I have to upload it I
have a collections of some
shoes uh let's see
and I will just install one I'll upload
this picture
it will take a bit of time let's wait
for a while
and once it's uploaded we will
we will update it
let's keep it like this
or we can
so we change our content place from that
to make it a fix in a place
so here we can
change this also
a pretty well
okay
so basically have this text happening a
little bit more
okay thing here
we have seen how we can resize it from
this scroll bar
and
so now let's add one more uh picture
over here to make it look more better
let's take a picture from here
change the image
and upload from
computer
[Music]
I have it from
oh
we will upload it again sorry
and we'll update it
let's resize it
let's turn it on
it's a make a taskbar for the top top
most of the screen we will have a home
page so we will write a text over here
that will be
I wanted to make it small a bit in size
we'll add another text
it's it will show about us
it will show about us section so we'll
write it over here
little small too
let's make same size
speak more small
allow let's make it more alarm
okay uh the next next session will be
services
and the last one is context one section
foreign
that is a start button like uh we are
keeping the start button over here so we
will we are keeping this here so let it
be here
so next uh what I'm going to do I'm
going to select
add a section and I'm going to just have
a blank section
um
here I'm gonna do first I will add a
picture first as a background
let's do it I will add one picture let's
see I have downloaded or not
yeah I will download it wait a minute
Let It Be upload
I will update it
it would be a hole for a whole page
so
let's add the pictures now
for another shoes
change the picture
I'm going to reopen this
and put
this
okay I'll update it
to add it
keep the pictures over here like
similarly we will upload three pictures
over here
after this let's keep it here
let's keep this here
we are going to add another title over
here
foreign
we will change the font for this
let's make this
yeah after this I we will start editing
the features of the shoes that's
go to chat TVD
let's take this first
paragraph
and make it small
we make it port
we will add another paragraph over here
similarly we will make it for this also
and last we will add
a contact us
plus we will add a contact a section
over here again
so this is the final output
of that GPD or how we use charge GPT and
air for our UI in ux design to create a
website or a web page or the land page
for the shows
started artificial intelligence large
language models and AI chatbots have
come a long way and today we have many
AI language models which are helping us
throughout various domains few examples
are Microsoft's Bank Google's bar open
AIS chat GPT Megatron T5 and many more
today we will be discussing about the
caliber of chat GPD and AI which can
leverage you and help you to build a
perfect business so few of the reasons
that you need to consider are the
decision making capabilities of chat GPT
and AI customer services that you can
offer through chat GPT and AI chat GPT
potential to create a content and its
potential to leverage data analysis and
charge up it is an AI capabilities to
provide sales and marketing for you and
run automation for you we will discuss
each one of these in detail so the first
one is decision making capabilities of
chat GPT in terms of raw processing
speed chat GPT can analyze and generate
text at a rapid base capable of
processing and generating responses much
faster than a human can type or think it
can quickly access and retrieve
information from its pre-trained
knowledge providing intermediate answers
to suggestions therefore chat GPT excels
in processing and generating text at
higher speeds however it cannot be
directly compared to humans in terms of
decision making abilities however it is
proof that it is 90 accurate in addition
making whereas humans tend to be
accurate at a rate of 80 to 85 percent
charge GPT is anyways stronger in terms
of decision making at this case followed
by that moving ahead to the next reason
that is the customer service that charge
gbd and AI can help you with if you
compare a human the customer support
representative reads the customer care
compared to human the customer support
representative has to read the
customer's query analyze the problem and
formulate the response this process may
take a few minutes or more depending on
the complexity of the issue and
representatives typing speed right but
when you compare it with chart GPD the
AI powered chatbot like chatgpt quickly
scans and comprehends the customer's
query it generates a response within
milliseconds providing intermediate
assistance as well so chat gbt is
proficient at providing customer
services at a much faster rate and it
can also eliminate you the cost of
hiring training and maintaining an
entire Army of customer services moving
ahead we have content creation if you
are a startup company or a company which
needs content creation for your product
then obviously you might end up hiring
Freelancers or a team of content
creators right but compared to humans
charge GPT is proficient at generating
content and can produce coherent and
contextually relevant text so you can
even save money by using the most
powerful and fully operational AI model
to create more versatile and highly
qualified content for you to avoid
hiring Freelancers and employees now
moving ahead the next reason is using AI
models for business data analysis AI can
assist you in data analysis by
leveraging its computational power and
advanced algorithms to possess and
extract valuable insights from large and
complex data sets AI algorithms can
automate data cleaning pattern
recognition and anomaly detection tasks
enabling faster and more accurate
results AI models can also perform
Predictive Analytics identifying Trends
and making forecasts based on historical
data additionally AI can facilitate data
visualization presenting information in
intuitive and interactive formats for
better understanding by automating
repetitive tasks and augmenting human
capabilities AI enhances the proficiency
efficiency accuracy and scalability of
data analysis procedures you can rely on
AI language model to extract transform
and load data and analyze your business
data and generate reports draw
projections and make data driven
decisions to help grow your company and
this also Awards you to hire and
maintain a huge Army of data analysts
which may produce some or the other
errors in real time
and next reason is sales and marketing
chat GPD can leverage sales and
marketing efforts in the following ways
customer engagement chargpt can engage
with potential customers and real time
answering their queries providing
product information and guiding them
through sales process it enhances
customer experience by delivering prompt
and personalized responses next is later
generation chargity can act as a virtual
assistant collecting and qualifying
leads by interacting through website
visitors it can gather relevant
information access customer needs and
provide initial assistance generating
valuable leads for the sales team 24 7
support share gpt's ability to operate
Around the Clock allows for continuous
customer support it can address
inquiries or for product recommendations
and resolve issues even outside regular
business apps improving customer
satisfaction and retention now instead
of hiring a team and manually marketing
your product on social media platforms
and spending thousands of dollars to run
paid marketing you can use AI models to
crack the algorithms and Market the
product to your target audience with
that let's proceed to the next reason
that is automating your tasks chat GPT
can automate business procedures in the
following ways the first one being
customer service charge APD can handle
customer inquiries Provide support and
resolve common issues through automated
chat interactions it reduces need for
human intervention saves time and
enables 24 7 customer support lead
qualifications chat GPT can engage with
potential customers ask qualifying
questions and and gather information to
assess their suitability as leads it
automates the initial stages of lead
qualification enabling sales team to
focus on most promising prospects only
next is data entry and processing chat
GPT can automate data entry tasks by
extracting relevant information from
various sources such as forms emails or
documents it reduces manual effort
improving accuracy and speeds up the
data processing appointment scheduling
charge GPD can integrate with scheduling
systems allowing customers to book
appointments or schedule meetings
automatically
finally workflow automation charge GPD
can integrate with business systems and
automated workflows it can initiate
actions send notifications or trigger
processes based on predefined rules
streamlining operations and improving
efficiency by automating various tasks
and processes chat Equity enhances
productivity reduces operational costs
and frees up human resources for
focusing on higher value activities with
their business so these were the few
important ways and reasons why charge
GPT and AI can help you make your
business if you are looking for ways to
generate passive income without putting
in too much effort thanks to the
advancement and artificial intelligence
and chat boards it's now possible to
earn money using these Technologies in
this video we'll explore some of the
effective ways to generate passive
income with Charity building
charitability is known for being the
world's smartest generative Ai and is
changing the game when it comes to
making money online with this
revolutionary free tool you can earn
with little skill and no Capital
required there is an exciting New Era of
artificial intelligence and now is the
perfect time to get involved and take
advantage of this opportunity people are
using chat Jeopardy for YouTube blogging
freelancing and for many other ways to
make money so let's dive in and discover
how to make money using shared Jeopardy
and generate various passive incomes
there are variety of ways that you can
make money using chair Deputy we'll
discuss few of them in this video and
we'll start with first we'll see the
list of all the ideas from which you can
make money the first is get business
ideas from chat Jeopardy second is
freelancing third is build a software
fourth is boost your affiliate marketing
with Chad Jeopardy's email expertise
with this leverage charge ability for
blogging success then access unlock the
potential of charge Deputy for affiliate
marketing and then we have utilized chat
jbd for ebook writing and
self-publishing this is the main thing
what people are doing to make money
using charity and then we have utilized
chat everybody to enhance your YouTube
channel and then we have writing lyrics
for music so starting them one by one
will start with get business ideas from
church Liberty by getting to know your
interest talent and obstacles chat jpd
can generate tailored business Concepts
that align with your expectations let's
Dive Right In and ask chat chipity for
some business ideas for a computer
science engineer who has experience in
digital marketing and sales chat
repeating and ask him that I am a
computer science graduate the computer
science engineer
with experience in sales and marketing
and what side Hustle
should I start
generate
around thousand dollars to generate
thousand dollars
income that would be per day
and that would be with minimum
investment amount
and this is
minimum investment
and I can also tell him how many hours I
can dedicate so I can dedicate it
to 10 hours
to the side Hustle
press enter
so you could see that chat Jeopardy
replies us that as a computer science
engineer with expense and sales and
marketing there's several side of the
results to generate thousand dollars
income per day
and he has stated the first one is
e-commerce then affiliate marketing
digital products you can create and sell
digital products such as ebooks okay
freelancing social media management and
YouTube channel you can start your
YouTube channel
so these are the ideas that you can get
from chat Jeopardy and but these ideas
tailored to user skills and interests
that I have put in now it's time to take
these ideas and discuss them further
with chat Jeopardy to conceptualize a
plan so consider important factors like
alternatively you can begin by stating
generate a new business idea poor
digital products you can write that and
he will guide you how you can start it
or you could just write
can you elaborate
the business
idea
of
digital
products
I am on
to start the side
hustle with this
and then you press enter and you can see
that it has started
the process for the business idea
certainly starting a side as well
centered around digital products can be
lucrative and fulfing Venture identify
your expertise
with manure areas of knowledge skills
and passion and then he has stated
choose your product format create
valuable content set up an online
platform Market your products build an
audience optimize for conversions
provide excellent customer support so
these are the parts he has stated and
moreover you can
elaborate those parts also you can just
ask chat tippity so how can I identify
my expertise and he will guide you with
that so you can go deep down and explore
any business idea
so this was the first method through
which you can generate income from chat
GPD and moving on the next would be
freelancing so take your freelancing
game to the next level with chair
Jeopardy this state of the art AI tool
is enabling professionals to earn extra
income and produce top quality content
that pose clients companies are even
offering incentives for those who
utilize this technology to create
polished well researched work so here
are some freelance services that you can
offer using chat CPT
starting with you can write blog or
website content using chatgpt for others
you can translate any language with jpt
you can craft compelling headlines and
calls to action with chat GPT and
moreover you can do create social media
content for posts or marketing for other
people or any advertising agency you can
write captivating short stories using
chat deputy and you can conduct hashtag
research using chatributing that is you
can find what is trending and offer your
services to other people and gain money
so these are the ways in which you could
freelance and have some money in your
pockets so you could just write a
command that would be write a blog post
and
you could write on any topic that would
be write a blog post code
U.S economy
so you could use this AI tool as your
means like what the what your client
required you can use for that and write
the perfect without plagiarism content
that will be blog post and you can
translate any language with chai triputi
you can write
competitive headlines and calls and you
can also write social media content that
would be you can use SEO research for
that and you can write short stories
also see that he has given you the blog
post on the topic U.S economy the
navigating uh the title is navigating
the current state of the U.S economic
Trends and insights and you can see that
it has given you six points and if you
want more you can just ask him to
elaborate
elaborate this
and I've found this blog post
in 800 words
so the thing you just have to do is
write the script write the prompt you
have to just prompt scripting and that
too in the easy language that is in
English and you will get all your
answers from the chat GPD
so now it will write the blog post that
would be in 800 words
so
it's good and moving on
what we'll do let's check out one of our
Learners what he has to say about our
courses you need to keep updating your
skills on a regular basis no matter what
level you're at I recently completed the
professional certificate program in Ai
and machine learning from Simply learn
in partnership with Purdue University
the course material was comprehensive
and the faculty was extremely
experienced The Faculty was able to
adjust their teaching style in order to
cater to the overall skill set of the
class in the rapidly evolving world of
technology it's important to keep up
Skilling for every working professional
stay relevant continue learning now
coming back so the third passive income
you could make using chat to pts
building a software imagine this
scenario you have an issue with your
online business
and you realize that many other people
are facing the same problem well here's
where chair deputy comes to the rescue
you can utilize chair Jeopardy to create
software using report provided by the AI
and then you can sell these software
tools to make money it's as simple as
that by leveraging chat Jeopardy's
powerful capabilities you can develop
innovative solutions to common problems
and turn them into valuable software
tools whether it's automating a task
streamlining a process or providing a
unique service the possibilities are
endless once you have created your
software tools you can Market them to
your target audience researching out to
those who can benefit from your solution
and guess what people are always looking
for convenient and efficient software
tools to enhance their business so
there's a ready Market waiting for you
so selling software tools not only
allows you to earn a steady income but
also impose others to overcome
challenges and improve their own
Ventures it's a win-win situation so if
you are a problem solver and have a neck
of four coding why not use charge Deputy
to create software tools that can make a
real happy start by identifying common
pain points that also you can ask from
chat Jeopardy you can just ask the chat
jpt I want to create a software to help
others during or in online processes in
online e-commerce so he'll give you
suggestions and then you can proceed
with those suggestions and create a
software and then you can sell it or you
can use for your own use
so now embrace the power chat jpt tap
into its coding expertise and unlock the
potential to create and sell software
tools so your journey to financial
success starts right here and moving on
we'll move to the next income source
that we can gain from chat jbd so you
can boost your affiliate marketing with
chat Jeopardy's email expertise so do
you know that charity processes
exceptional writing skills it's true
this incredible chatbot can drop
convincing emails that motivate users to
take action whether it's clicking on
affiliate links making purchases or
subscribing to Services charity has
caught you power that's impressive
ability to generate engaging content you
can Captivate your audience and compel
them to take the desired actions so
we'll get back to the chat GPT and ask
him that
I am an email marketer
and need to
sell my CRM software
so write an email
only
so I can attract
customer
and make them bite
okay
now you could see that it is writing
email for you and you can launch your
email affiliate marketing campaign also
now that we understand the power of
child supporting let's discuss how you
can Kickstart our email affiliate
marketing campaign the first step is to
choose an affiliate program that aligns
with your Niche whether it's Amazon's
Spotify Shopify convertkit or any other
program make sure it suits your target
audience next it's time to build an
email list of potential customers who
are generally interested in your
promoted products or Services you can
use lead magnets or employ other
effective methods to encourage email
signups you could see that he has
written the email that is I hope this
email finds you well as an email
marketed person okay this is for me and
you could start from here at your
company we have developed a powerful CRM
solution tailored specifically for email
marketers like yourself our software
combines Advanced features user friendly
okay here is written for uh email
marketers only as targeted audience that
is email marketer no issue you can ask
him to change that and like you can
craft compelling emails with charity and
this is where chat Jeopardy truly shines
with its assistance you can create
highly engaging emails that not only
inform users about the benefits of the
products but also Inspire them to click
on your affiliate links and make
purchases imagine having a chat about by
your site imagine having a chatbot by
your side helping you write captivating
emails effortlessly by incorporating
persuasive language compelling
storytelling and personalized touch your
emails will stand out in crowded inboxes
and generate higher click-through rates
so this is how chat Jeopardy can help
you in email marketing now the next
method is leverage child Jeopardy for
blogging success in the realm of
blogging chair Jeopardy offers an array
of advantages that can elevate your
content creation Journey so the first is
content generation so Unleash the Power
of this AI driven tool to spank your
creativity and overcome writer's block
chat GPT assist bloggers by generating
ideas crafting outlines anyone providing
complete routes for blog posts say
goodbye to our spend on research the
charge APD you can access relevant
information statistics and facts and
mere seconds elevate your blogging game
and Unleash Your Potential with this in
invaluable source
and then you can add it and proof it
using charge update if you have written
any content and get any content written
you could just write what we have
already written that was write a blog
post on U.S economic that we have seen
in freelancing uh side Hustle but here
you can write and not only write but
also if you have added some points with
your research you can proofread and edit
by using charge APD that is for bloggery
proves to be a valuable asset by
offering assistance in editing
proofreading and enhancing the overall
readability of your blog post it
provides suggestions and Corrections for
spelling grammar and comprehension
reducing errors and ensuring Clarity let
chat Jeopardy Define your writing and
ensure a blog posts shine with
professionalism the next what you can do
for your blogging journey is keyword
research and SEO optimization so this is
a fundamental aspect of successful
blogging chargipti becomes your trusted
companion in optimizing your blog post
for search engines it suggests relevant
keywords to include guides you on a
structure in your content for maximum
visibility and offer steps to enhance
your online presence maximize your blogs
reach and attract more organic traffic
in chat GPS SEO expertise and then we
have audience engagement and I will also
show you how we can relate keywords so
for SEO you could just search that would
be gaming related
SEO keywords
for and the topic could be online
shopping
and press enter so here are some related
SEO keywords for online shopping you
could see all these you would mention
these on your backlinks if you have
website or you could add into your blog
posts hashtags which can gain you rank
when searched so moving back the next
was audience engagement so engaging your
audience is key to building a thriving
blow charity can assist you in
connecting with the readers on a deeper
level it towards conversation starters
answer common questions and addresses
concerns from your Audience by
leveraging Charity's capabilities you
can post on meaningful interactions
cultivated lower following and force
lasting connections with your readers by
harnessing the power of charge Deputy
bloggers can consistently produce high
quality content Captivate their target
audience bolster their online presence
and generate passive income embrace the
potential of charge deputy and embark on
an exciting blog Journey it will leave a
lasting impact so moving on we'll now
see another side herself that is unlock
the potential of chat Jeopardy for
affiliate marketing and you could do
easily affiliate marketing if you have
this blogging thing
so affiliate marketing opens up a world
of earning possibilities and chat
Jeopardy can be your trusted Ally on
this rewarding Journey users of charge
Deputy can leverage its capabilities to
generate income through affiliate
marketing this powerful tool provides a
seamless Avenue for promoting Goods
services and Brands all while learning a
commission based on resulting sales
embarking on an affiliate marketing
Venture requires thoughtful planning as
a blogger or content creator you must
carefully select the medium through
which you will build your audience
whether it's through captivating
articles engaging audio content or
compelling videos you have the freedom
to choose the format that aligns with
your strengths and resonates with your
target audience when you have
established your audience building
medium chair Deputy steps into support
your affiliate marketing efforts this AI
driven tool empowers you to craft
persuasive content that effectively
promotes the products or Services you
are affiliated with by collaborating
with chai Jeopardy you can tap into its
exceptional writing skills and create
captivating promotional materials that
resonate with with your audience as you
implement your affiliate marketing
strategy chargibility becomes an
invaluable resource it helps you to
draft engaging articles record
compelling audio content or script
captivating videos that highlight the
benefits and value of the products or
services that you are promoting so
remember affiliate marketing is a
process that requires dedication and
perseverance through consistent effort
and support of charge GPT you can unlock
the potential of earning substantial
income by promoting products and
services that resonate with your
audience and this was for the affiliate
marketing and the next big thing is
utilize chair Jeopardy for ebook writing
and self-publishing so are you a
passionate writer seeking fresh and
innovative ideas look no further charge
every day revolutionizes your writing
experience in a recent report that
revealed that AI written ebooks have
experienced a remarkable search on
Amazon so you could just go and charge
deputy and ask him
I want to write a self
help book
add to
Black version free
okay I think yeah no spelling is great
black person free
and it's
should have
resonating
chapters there's no needing
chapters
so
provide me
with a list of chapters
as you can see that
it will Define you and you can also ask
the title for the book and it will give
you the perfect title and you can see
the chapters that is introducing setting
the stage for personal growth
discovering your authentic self
cultivating a positive mindset and after
that you can ask chat Deputy to
elaborate these topics that would be in
some words in some pages and you can use
the same content to write a book and you
can also ask the title from the chat jpd
as you create a companion the
possibilities are boundless you don't
need to possess the skills of literary
genius to make an impact in the e-book
Market Kindle Direct publishing offers
seamless platform to Showcase your book
and make it easily accessible to
enthusiastic readers while leveraging
charge Deputy to assist in writing your
ebook you will save precious time and
energy allowing you to concentrate on
marketing and promoting your work
effectively so this is how you can write
ebooks and generate income
using chair GPD moving on we have next
passive income that is utilized chargedy
to enhance your YouTube channel
is an invaluable tool that can assist
you in generating captivating video
ideas you can ask him the video ideas
also and this is the creative block
charge if you can even cool the extra
mile by creating a script for YouTube
videos
so let's tap into the creative pros and
we'll ask chair jpt
I want to create a YouTube video
on topic
uh GDP
that is close domestic product and
I need your help
writing
the script for that
so you could see that chair GPD has
started its work so it's showing welcome
back to our channel in today's video
we'll be diving into the fascinating
world of GB GDP what exactly is GDP and
why is it such an important measure of
our country's economy so you can see
that it has created the script for your
YouTube video and it is also telling you
the scenes
so this is how you could leverage your
Japanese capabilities and that can give
you YouTube channel a significant boost
helping you create engaging content and
capture the attention of your audience
so start exploring the possibilities
with chair Deputy today and witness your
channel Thrive so moving on the next we
have is writing lyrics for music so when
it comes to music the words we use in
songs are super important they have the
power to make us feel all kinds of
emotions and connect with people and now
there's a cool tool called chargabity
that can help you write awesome song
lyrics with Chad Jeopardy you can take
your ideas and turn them into beautiful
words that touch people's heart it's
like having a virtual writing buddy that
help you come up with catchy lines and
cool Rhymes you can play around with
different ways to express yourself and
make your lyrics stand out so you can
chat GPT to write lyrics and hence your
professional prospects through
enrollment in post-graduate program in
Ai and machine learning from Simply
learn one year of experience is
preferred to enroll in this course hurry
up and enroll Now find the course Link
in the description box today we have a
variety of AI language models that are
fully operational and have the potential
not just to decode your question but
also smart enough to understand the
intention behind your questions are the
countless number of development and the
emerging ones like Megatron Albert
Electra T5 and many more these three
models are currently ruling the space of
AI language models Bing Bard and charity
and today we will understand the
differences similarities and the
abilities that make them stand out and
try to decide which one is the best hey
everyone welcome to Simply launch
YouTube channel and today we bring you
the Bing versus the Google bar the chat
GPD but before we begin if these are the
type of videos you would like to watch
hit that subscribe button and the bell
icon to never miss an update from Simply
learn if you are an aspiring artificial
intelligence engineer looking for an
online training and certification from
the prestigious universities and in
collaboration with leading experts so
that you have the most robust Foundation
skills knowledge and what it takes to
become the best then search no more
simply learns post graduation Pro
program in artificial intelligence from
Purdue University in collaboration with
IBM should be your right choice for more
details use the link in the description
box below also want to get access to
more informative content like this one
get subscribed to us and hit the Bell so
that you are the first to get to know
when we host with that in mind let's
start with the elephant in the room that
is the chat GPD
Chad GB was released on the 30th of
November 2022 it uses the GPT llm to
elaborate llm as an abbreviation for
large language model and chat GPT is
globally available to its users using
the generative pre-trained Transformer
also called as chat GPT llm with 1
trillion parameters as its variables
loaned during the model training now the
Bing
Microsoft was one of the largest
investors in open AI Bing is an AI
language model created in collaboration
with open Ai and publicly released on
the 4th of May 2023 Bing uses the same
data set that chat GPD uses Bing has an
edge over chart GPD as Microsoft
integrates its Prometheus with about 135
billion parameters now next up we have
Bard Bard is Google's answer to chat gbd
with limited capabilities and lukewarm
responses it was released on 21st of
March 2023 but initially started off
with Lambda llm with a caliber of 137
billion parameters Google's CEO eshos
Bard will switch to pathway model named
as palm 2 llm with about 400 billion
plus parameters to take on chat GPD
head-on head in generating responses and
the application codes and Pro programs
with the details discussed let's move
ahead to some of the important
parameters to be considered to discuss
the differences firstly user interface
and experience chat GPD has a simple and
subtle interface making it easy to
understand and get along with the usage
so chat gpt's user interface looks
something like this chat GPT has a
simple Dark theme interface focusing on
providing users with high quality
language processing capabilities rather
than immersive visuals you can ask
questions get answers and even you can
ask to enhance or optimize the answer
according to your needs again user needs
to manually request chat GPD the other
hand Bing is more inclined towards
giving a blissful visual experience to
their users by choosing brilliant
background images colorful interfaces
and emojis
so a typical Bing user interface looks
something like this in addition to that
it is backed up by chat gpd's dataset
and Prometheus llm to help users with
the best and class answers to their
questions it even delivers three
different answers at the same time
creative balanced and precise are the
three variants and you can choose the
best ones which suits your requests now
lastly bad bar is a little different
from others unlike others but just dumps
the answers at once enthusiasts call it
fast but it misses the human touch of
giving the answers in a word by word
typing minor yet similar to Bing it
manages to give you different versions
of the answers besides that but has a
decent interface and its logo shines
with multiple colors giving you the
feeling of part processing the data to
give you a better result now let's try
to ask a few most frequently asked
questions
let's ask with a simple one are you
friends with
chat GPD and Bing
you can see The Shining logo of Bot and
you have just seen the way how Google
bot answers you it just dumps the answer
now if you go or if you ask the same
question to the other one select charge
gbd and Wing let's see how they respond
and you can see you have other drives as
well right so you can see track 1 draft
2 and draft three so you can choose any
ones which you feel are more optimized
and you know deliverable according to
your requests right now let's go back to
think right now let's ask the same
question
are you friends with
chat GPD
and but
see the word by word typing approach of
Bing and charge APD gave you a little
more immersive feeling that somebody is
really talking to you right and you also
have the freedom of
choosing the answer wisely right so it
gives you three different options which
are creative balanced and precise right
and on just one single scroll you have
the Bing search open here right this is
one other good way of using Bing in the
in case if you have any questions that
are unanswered or which did not satisfy
you you can also go back to Bing and you
can manually search for the data and get
the information right now let's get back
to chat GPD
here let's ask this in question
are you
friends with
Bing and bad
me
so that's how individual AI models
respond to each other and now let's get
back to the next point of discussion
which is what is the data or history
about the questions you asked or the
prompts you have opened that each one of
these stores
so this is about the conversation
history or the prompt that you have with
in division one of these AI models
first comes the chat GPD charge GPD
claims they do not store any data about
its interaction with its users but in
chat GPD you can access the prompts and
questions you asked you can also export
your transcripts in chat GPD on the
other hand we have bing bing says they
do not have any history or prompts of
your previous conversations as well and
lastly but but is a little mix and match
at both so what bar does is it Stores
Only the prompts whereas in chat GPT
when you ask a question it will store
the question and the onsite gave you but
but it will only store The Prompt that
is the question you asked and note the
answer it gave to you so with that the
next point of discussion would be the
mobile version of each one of these as
of now chat gbd hasn't released any of
the official mobile application version
yet and on the other hand on wing it has
just one click of a button and you can
click it and then Launches on your
mobile phone and when has a mobile
variant with similar and much better
Aesthetics that can get started on a
touch of an app launcher and lastly we
have Bard Bart has a similar approach to
its mobile variant Google has enabled
part usage in Google mobile application
as well and now comes the number of
questions asked disclaimer if you want
to work on a project presentation or
thesis choose your AI model wisely
because if you are close to wrapping up
your project and the AI model says sorry
pal you're out of your wishes Yes you
heard me right a few of these language
models have a limitation on the number
of questions asked on one single topic
or one single keyword or one single
concept let's look into details before
we proceed to the next part of this
video let's take a minute to hear from
our Learners who have experienced
massive success and their careers hey
I'm Sharia Jaleel I live in Ontario
Canada I have been in I.T sector for the
past 20 years I recently took the
professional certificate program in
artificial intelligence and machine
learning the course has changed the way
I look at things and helped me back some
amazing freelance projects I started my
career in 1999 and over the years I have
worked with many companies my last tenor
was with IBM Canada my aim was to
restart my carrier and learn something
that would help accelerate my career
I thought artificial intelligence can
make me Future Ready
the course in artificial intelligence
and machine learning is provided by
simply learn in association with Purdue
University which is why I chose the
course I did not have high expectations
from online course but my experience was
simply awesome
quality of interaction within the course
was simply amazing the course faculty
was also very experienced and
knowledgeable
after the course my knowledge has grown
manifold I have immensely benefited from
Python and coding skills I am able to
get some new freelance projects
also I am planning to start a an AI
based startup with my friend where I
feel that the learning from the course
to be very helpful I am really delighted
and happy
create meaningful content on YouTube and
I talk about new technologies and what
kind of courses professionals should be
taking along with many other topic I
definitely recommend this course to
everyone after all when it comes to new
skills to advance your career there
should be no compromise you should
always learn from the band
[Music]
first comes chat gbd chat GPD takes 25
questions on a single keyword or a
single subject or a single topic of
discussion post that it refrains from
answering your questions
same with Bing it takes no more than 20
questions on single keyword or a single
topic or a single concept
but now comes Brad
Brad is a little different Brad kind of
said this takes a little too high it
almost has no limits to your questions
you can ask any number of questions to
God and that can be a real deal breaker
lastly we will differentiate these AI
models based on their productivity yes
exactly we do know all these three
models are smart but how smart exactly
how humanly are they how close are they
in convincing you with an optimistic
answer what's their potential to charge
a hypothetical question and give you a
balanced answer sounds interesting right
let's get started first let's start with
chat GPD so let's say I want to learn Ai
and machine learning so obviously this
should be able to teach me that let's
ask it
can you
teach me
artificial intelligence
machine learning
brilliant it gave me a brief about
artificial intelligence machine learning
types of machine learning and deep
learning in one go and it also convince
you here right yes as an AI model I can
certainly help you with that right so
it's a good answer now let's try to ask
a little different one
or
can it plan an itinerary or can it buy
me a product online or can it do some
other things like booking me an Uber
right so let's try 10 new
or change
and
line
training program
for
Ai and ml
brilliant charge GPA knows its limits
right as an AI model I cannot directly
purchase online right it's giving you
the brutal truth here that's good and
apart from that it also gave you a
step-by-step procedure for buying your
course to your research check the
curriculum check the instructor what's
the format what's the cause right a few
parameters which you might want to
consider before buying a course right so
now let's try to question the same
queries to Wing So since Bing and chart
GPT share the same training data set I
could expect a similar answer but let's
see it is taking a while I guess
Prometheus is a little
slower compared to GPD okay there might
be a connection issue let's ask the
question once again
wow it's way too better than Char gbd so
it is even asking you details on if you
if you are looking for a specific topic
or a general overview let's say I would
need a general overview
I could straight away say Bing is a
little more smarter and productive
compared to chat jpd but still we have
one more Contender to compare with but
right
so there might be again the internet
connection
now let's say we refresh Bing once again
and straight away ask the second
question what we had right that is can
you buy me a course
online course
for learning
artificial
thing did gave me a good answer for the
previous question let's see what kind of
an answer it gives me now I'm sorry but
I'm not capable of making online
purchases however I can find you some
online courses for learning AI would you
like me to search for some options
brilliant
so this is a little more optimized
answer compared to chat GPD ones and it
is also honest it does know its limits
fine it can help you search for some
online courses but again a chart GPD
gave us some parameters to consider
right so I would give or I would choose
to tie them up here they are on a tie
now our last Contender that is part
let's try to ask the same questions to
part so here is bad now let's try to ask
questions too but let's say can you
teach me
learning
you can see the bad logo shining there
now it should be dumping the answer
anytime soon yeah of course we do miss
that humanly touch off giving the answer
in a word by word typing way
let's refresh and ask the question again
can you teach me
this is a little too straightforward I'm
a language model and don't have the
capacity to help you out
so
okay let's not give up here let's try to
ask the second question can you purchase
an online
training program
to me
to learn
machine learning
yes I can help you purchase an online
program for machine learning here are a
few things that you need to consider
good
it's not being brutally honest here it
is saying it can help you out so again
what I intended to expect here was you
cannot just directly buy an online
program right you need some details
credentials and everything to purchase
so again it is the answer and it is
definitely giving you suggestions
similar to chat GPD but a little
different which focuses on your learning
style level of experience your budget
good nice way to answer some questions
like this one so all these three ones
are brilliant and good in their own way
so it might be a little difficult to
declare who's the winner as of now since
the bad AI model is going to switch to
Palm 2 and we are expecting some updates
to each one of these with that we can
consider currently they are standing
next to each other with similar
capabilities and better enhancement in
different fields so with that having
said we can conclude this session on
chat GPD versus Link versus bot and if
you would like me to answer the
conclusion I would say well it seems
like we all have our strengths and
weaknesses at the end of the day it
comes to word users value the most that
they want a visually appealing interface
strong privacy protections or the
ability to converse with an AI language
model it's up to them to decide so you
are the viewers and you can decide the
winner of this particular battle on chat
gbd vs Bing versus bad deputy and
googlebot are the two AI chatbots you
must have heard about they bought an
immense change in the way we operate now
from web development to digital
marketing from cloud computing to cyber
security they are now everywhere you
just name it and they have it trust me
the use of these chat Bots has changed
everything if you want to create a
complete YouTube video just ask them and
rest the show they'll take care for your
task not just that but if you want to
create a search engine optimized content
whether it be for your website or on
YouTube these AI tools can help you with
such content search engine optimization
is not easy it takes a lot to optimize
your content so that people can get to
see it on top what are these AI tools
threat to people engaged in search
engine optimization in this video we'll
not discuss what these AI tools can do
for you but we'll discuss if AI tools
like chat GPT or googlebot will take
over SEO or not but before that if you
enjoy watching these videos and find
them interesting please subscribe to our
Channel because we bring the best videos
for you daily hit the Bell icon to get
notified whenever we drop a new video
also if you wish to create your own AI
tool by gaining expertise in the field
of AI and machine learning then simply
learns Ai and machine learning bootcamp
is the right choice for you with this
boot camp you will gain expertise in
artificial intelligence and machine
learning by learning the top skills
required in this two week not just that
but there are many other attractive
features of this boot camp like 25 plus
Hands-On projects across industry
verticals with integrated Labs will help
you understand the concepts better
industry relevant Capstone projects in
three domains make sure that you have
mass this technology a bootcamp
certificate from Caltech ctma is worth
mentioning in your scene live virtual
classes led by industry experts Hands-On
projects and integrated labs simple
learns career service is here to help
you get noticed by the top hiring
companies several other features are
also there in this boot camp in simple
terms this Ai and machine learning boot
camp helps you become an expert in
artificial intelligence and machine
learning a few of the skills you will
Master with this program are supervised
learning unsupervised learning
recommendations
networks deep learning chat GPT and much
more so hurry up and enroll Now find the
AI and machine learning bootcamp program
Link in the description box so let's
start this video with a small
introduction to search engine
optimization the goal of SEO is to make
a website more visible and bring in
income from natural traffic it entails
crafting excellent content for a
specific audience and optimizing a
website for search engines online
marketers employ AI to accomplish
various tasks such as keyword research
content optimization and Link building
more quickly businesses can boost their
ranks and increase their revenue by
using AI in SEO strategies additionally
by automating routine processes it can
save time and resources also if you want
to master the field of search engine
optimization and digital marketing
simply learns postgraduate program in
digital marketing is clearly the right
choice for you this postgraduate program
in collaboration with Purdue will help
you master search engine optimization
content marketing web analytics keyword
management and research website
management and optimization URL
management search psychology keyword
research Advanced ad features and more
not only these skills but you will also
learn a number of tools like SC ranking
HootSuite Google ads Keyword Planner and
much more so hurry up and find the
course Link in the description box for
more details hear it from our Learners
who have experienced massive success in
digital marketing through this course
I moved to United States four years ago
to live with my family
I have a background in social media by
doing the same was difficult here
more so because my English is not that
good last year I decided to pursue the
professional certification program in
digital marketing from Purdue University
offered by simple learner I like that it
could provide such as flexible schedule
for attending the live classes it came
with a recorded feature with a blessing
for working professionals like me tell
me make significant progress I am
already using these kids to sell my
products online I believe that I have
come one step closer to living my dream
life in America so let's talk about SEO
developments with chat GPT and Google
bar and notably the influence AI is
anticipated to have on search engines
have been highlighted by the recent
launches of Google's bar and chat Deputy
assistant bin although these recent
advancements pose a severe engine they
also present opportunities for digital
marketers to seize in the world full of
SEO things change all the time and Subs
are never stable the page that a search
engine displays as a result of a user's
search query is known as the search
engine result page or server this is why
it's important to be able to change with
the times and benefit from from new
technological developments digital
marketers increasingly use AI for
keyword research heading ideas and
content optimizations this is so they
can concentrate on the jobs that need
human interaction small sites May
produce original SEO friendly material
much more quickly with chatgibility then
they could without it for instance
however it's vital to remember that this
is only a portion of the process it can
assist you with creating and providing
meta descriptions and titles keyword
research heading recommendations for
pages and posts article ideation and
composing copy so let's talk about the
role of AI in keyword research every
business utilizes AI to increase
productivity automate labor intensive
operations and make data driven choices
numerous Industries including finance
and banking e-commerce retail media
gaming research space exploration
Transportation automative medicine
manufacturing security and uses it in
various ways the Google AdWords Keyword
Planner and the Google Trends tool are
two of the most widely used free
artificial intelligence keyword research
tools you may find keywords with a lot
of search volume and little competition
using these tools another crucial aspect
to take into account when choosing
keywords for your website is intent this
is so because users frequently have a
purpose while searching for goods and
services although it might be
challenging to ensure your website
appears high on search engine visual
Pages especially with Google's algorithm
adjustments SEO companies and marketers
must constantly check their websites to
make sure that their websites are not
falling in the servers they can use AI
to automatically analyze search traffic
statistics and website content to spot
potential issues before they arise they
can then address these problems and
offer consistent organic rankings this
is a game changer for SEO companies and
marketers who realize on manual SEO
efforts to get traffic to their websites
but the main question is will chat GPT
or googlebot take over SC the answer is
clearly a big why chat Bots like chat
deputy and Bart cannot replace SEO they
can help generate content for your
website or video but SEO involves more
than just content creation it includes
tasks keyword research link building and
Technical SEO where you'll need an SEO
expert because chatbots can't decide how
to build links and which links will get
you more organic traffic SEO is
constantly changing due to search engine
algorithms search engines like Google
and Bing regularly update their
algorithms making SEO a dynamic field
SEO requires human judgment and decision
making the end of discussion because
determining which keywords to Target and
which links to build required expertise
and human decision making a chatbot
can't do it in fact the real power of
search engine optimizations lies not in
their mechanical abilities but in their
creativity and ability to understand
what people are searching for and why
that's something that AI Technologies
may never be able to replicate and it's
what makes human SEO experts such a
valuable asset so while it's true that
AI Technologies may eventually be able
to take over some of the aspects of SEO
there's still plenty of rooms for human
experts to thrive whether you are a
seasoned SEO professional or just
starting out here's still a place for
you in this exciting and ever evolving
field let's keep an eye on the
developments in AI technology and see
how it can augment and enhance our
skills rather than replacing them
entirely who knows with the power of AI
and human expertise combined the future
of SEO may be even brighter than we can
imagine so with that we have come to the
end of this discussion although everyone
can have different opinions on this but
I hope you guys must have gotten right
why these AI tools are not a threat to a
c if you still have any questions or
doubts let us know in the comment
section below and our team of experts
will help you at the audience here we
wrap up complete chat GPT course for
beginners if you like this video share
it with your friends if you have any
queries feel free to add it in the
comment section below stay tuned with
latest updates on technology by
subscribing to Simply learn Channel
thanks for watching staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here